University instructor Dave Gray gets straight to the point and he will take you from knowing nothing
to understanding advanced HTML concepts. Hello and welcome to four hours of HTML tutorials
and instruction. This video is made up of 10 tutorials for learning HTML that build upon each
other much like the chapters of a book. Throughout the lessons in this video, I will mention links
being available in the description below. I've compiled all of these links into one GitHub
resource that you will find in the description. Hi, I'm Dave Gray and I'm the creator of these
HTML tutorials. You can subscribe to my YouTube channel for more tutorials like this one. You
can also follow me on Twitter and if you're feeling generous you can even buy me a cup of coffee.
A quick thank you to Bo at FreeCodeCamp for sharing this video and to everyone at FreeCodeCamp
for providing such an outstanding resource that helps people learn how to code for free.
It's truly my honor to contribute this video. Let's get started learning HTML with chapter one.
What is HTML? HTML is an acronym that stands for Hypertext Markup Language
and Hypertext Markup Language, HTML, is the most basic building block of the web. It defines the
meaning and structure of web content and hypertext refers to links that connect web pages to each
other and that can be within a single website or from one website to another. Overall, HTML uses
markup to annotate text images and other content for display in a web browser and you can see an
example of some of these markup elements here but before we begin creating a web page and using
these markup elements we need to get the necessary tools. So let's start with a web browser. If you
don't have one or if you're curious what I will be using in this series I'll be using the Google
Chrome browser and you can download that at google.com slash chrome. So if you don't have that
and want to use that go ahead and download and install now and then come back to the tutorial.
Also I will be using an extension and we go to chrome.google.com slash web store to get
extensions for the chrome browser and there if you want to use the extension that I'm going to use
it's called dark new tab and you can press enter to search for that and once you've completed your
search you'll see dark new tab offered by Keller which is the one that I have added and you can
see added here. I'll click on that and once you're inside the page for dark new tab you should have
an install button here. Since I already have it installed this is now a remove button for me.
What this does is when you open a new tab in the browser it uses a dark page instead of a light
page and I use dark mode whenever possible so I prefer that. If you see me open a new tab in this
development series you'll probably see a dark tab like this one. From there we need to get a code
editor and the industry standard right now and what I prefer to use is Visual Studio Code. Again
you can use other code editors to write your HTML code but if you go to code.visualstudio.com
you'll be able to download Visual Studio Code for free and there you can download for Windows if
you're on Windows like I am or you can click other platforms and it's also available for Linux
and Mac OS. So now would be a good time to go ahead and download Visual Studio Code and install
your code editor and go ahead and open that up and then come back to the video. Okay I am now
assuming you have installed Visual Studio Code and have opened it up and you may see something
like this or you may see a welcome screen. What you need to do is create a folder on your computer
and we will put our files inside that folder. So if I go to the file menu and choose open folder
you can see once this pops up what folder I am in the HTML course folder in Windows
and then I've created an 01 underscore lesson folder. So if I highlight that and select the
folder I am now inside that folder and ready to create my first HTML file. So if you see the file
tree over here on the left and it's currently empty if you don't click this icon in the top left
which is the file explorer and that will hide or show this file explorer. We're going to create
the plus button or click the plus button here for new file and create a new file.
Now we'll type index.html as that is always the file name that is expected to launch a website
and you always want to keep your file names lowercase and with no spaces. Now Windows will not
complain if you put a space or use upper or lowercase. However when we host our files on a web
server a web server will differentiate many times and that can cause problems. So the naming
convention is to always use lowercase no spaces you can use hyphens dashes and then end each file
and dot html. Okay we have an empty index.html file. Let's create our first html element and as you
might guess the first html element we'll create is html. So if we type html all lowercase and press
tab in visual studio code it creates the tags and by tags that is often interchanged as a word with
element. However the element consists of the starting and ending tag and everything in between
but here we might just be referring to the starting also called the opening tag or the ending also
called the closing tag. So we refer to html tags but every page starts and ends with the html
opening and closing tags and everything else on the page goes between those tags. After creating
our html element html pages have two main areas and one area contains data that is not seen on
the page but is considered to be metadata about the page and that is the head area. So just type
head not header but head and press tab and now we have our head element and we will put metadata
about the page inside this area but the next area is the page that every or is the part of the page
that everybody sees in the browser and that is held within the body element. So type body and
press tab and now we have our two major sections of our page that are both inside of the html
element. We have a head section and a body section. Now inside the head we'll just put one piece of
metadata today and it really won't start with the word meta. We'll come back to that word
in the future. We're going to create a title element and give our page a title. Let's just
call this my first web page and this will stay inside of the html document. Now I just pressed
control s which saved the document. You otherwise would see a dot up here by the index.html so I
saved that and I am using an auto formatter. Visual Studio Code may or may not do that for
you when you save your file. If you want that you can go to the extension icon over here and search
for a prettier extension and I'm not sure if mine is enabled or I'm using something else right now
we'll have to check. Now mine is disabled but I do recommend this one. Prettier is a code formatter
that will auto format your code but Visual Studio Code may do some of that as well but if you want
to use Prettier go ahead and click install and you can use that as well. So I'll close out that
Prettier tab. Go back to the file explorer here so we see our index.html on the left instead of the
extensions and now we can see our html is formatted in a very easy to read manner. We have our html
element and then the head element and then the body element and they're separated by spaces.
Very easy to read and we have a title inside of the head. Again the title will not be seen
inside of the browser in the body of the page but I will show you very shortly where we do see it.
Inside of the body element though let's put an h1 element which stands for a heading and it is
the biggest heading we could put. You only put one h1 element per page and that should be saying
what your page is about. It doesn't necessarily have to be the same text that is in the title
but here we're just going to put hello world as is the tradition for creating your first file in
any language you're learning and so we have hello world on the page and we have my first web page
in the head section. Let's add one more element in the body of the page
and this is a paragraph element that starts and ends just with the letter p but notice each of
our tags of course start with this less than and then end with a greater than and then the ending
tag you'll notice has a slash but all we have to do in Visual Studio Code is type p and press tab
and it creates both for us. So we're going to put some text inside of our paragraph and here we'll
just put this is my first web page with a period in the sentence and save. Once again I'm pressing
control s on the keyboard to save. You can go to the file menu and from there you can also choose
save but you'll notice the shortcut is control and the letter s. We're almost ready to view our web
page but before we do remember the extensions we went to. I want to show you just a few if you want
your Visual Studio Code to look like mine. One thing to draw your attention to is when I created
an index.html file I have the little icon for html5 beside it. You may not have that but if we click on
extensions and then we can delete prettier that I searched for before type vs code dash icons
there you'll find the extension that will add that to your vs code as well so you can install. I
already have it installed so mine says uninstall and that will add icons as you create files and
it might add the icon up here as well in the tab and that's how you see the icon here beside my
index.html in the file explorer. So visually it helps you see what type of file you're working
with quickly without even reading everything. After that extension let's go ahead and click
the extensions icon again and then search for github theme. I am using a specific theme
which I prefer dark mode in everything that I do so I am using the github theme extension and it
has light and dark themes. I believe I'm using the default dark theme this might be bright for a
second but I'll click set color theme and yes it switched back to light but I choose github dark
default and then yours will look much like mine. Now these previous extensions have been optional
but one that I say is a must for you to install is called live server. So let's pull up live server
by ritwick day. I'll click on that and you want to install live server because it's going to help
us view our web pages. So go ahead and install live server and after you have it installed
we'll go ahead and take a look at the web page we've created. Okay with that installed I'm going
to close that tab. I'll come back to the file explorer here to show the file and now if you
have live server installed you should be able to right click and open with live server and once we
choose open with live server it opens our browser and we can see our web page it says hello world
this is my first web page. In addition in the tab at the top it says my first web page so that is
where the title goes at the very top of the browser in the tab. Now this is very bright and I have
mentioned that I prefer dark mode so let's go back to visual studio code and I'm just going to paste
in some quick styling that is actually CSS. Once again this is optional but it will save my eyes
and possibly yours as we work through this tutorial. So once we're back in visual studio code
just underneath the title in the head section I'm going to paste this in. I'll quickly describe it.
I put in a style element and that allows me to put in some quick CSS and I changed the font size to
make it just a little larger and then I changed the background color to a dark color and I changed
the font color to an off white color called white smoke and that's all I did. We're not really
learning CSS here but this will save our eyes going forward if you want to make these changes.
If you prefer the white with dark text that is fine too but now that I've saved this the beauty
of live server is that it automatically reloads our page for us in the browser. So let's go back
to the browser and look at our update and now you can see our web page is in dark mode and we have
a little bit larger text here as well. It did not change our title from the head because that just
goes into the tab of the browser. Also notice the address. This is an IP address and then we have a
colon and this is a port number but this is on your own computer. This is not on mine. I can't
go onto the web and see your page that we just created. We haven't loaded it to the web. It is
just running on your computer but this is the way to view web pages as we create them which creates
your own local server. It's what's called a dev environment and that is preferred. What you don't
want to do in chrome is try to open a file like you would in word or some other document browser
or even visual studio code how we open files. That's not how you want to view a web page. You
want to use a development server and that's what we're doing with live server in visual studio
code. Now if you ever want to stop the server down here in the bottom you can see the port number 5500
and it says click to close server. So I can just click that. It says disposing and now we have a
go live button which you can also use. You can also right click on your document and choose stop
or open with live server. Now we would once again since we stopped that we would need to open with
live server to have a live web page that responds to changes we make and notice how it opened a new
tab here instead of our old tab. Our old tab the server for that page closed so we close that out
and now we're using this one because this is going to show our most recent changes. Now after we've
created a web page how do we know if we have errors or not? Well that's where a validation
service comes into play and this is the W3C markup validation service. W3C stands for the
World Wide Web Consortium that really makes the standards for the web overall. What we want to do
to check our page is click file upload because remember our web page is really not on the web
it's just on our computer. Your web page is on your computer and mine is on my computer. So let's
click file upload and from here we're going to choose the file on the computer and we get a
browse window and now I'm going to click HTML tutorials and then I have an HTML course folder
and then the zero lesson one folder that we just created and there is the index.html file we've
been working with so I'll click open and now that it's here we can click check and we're going to
get some errors and we'll go over those. Okay now that we have checked our page we have got a
warning and a couple of errors so there are things we need to fix in our HTML file. Let's address
these in order with the first warning says consider adding a lang attribute to the HTML
start tag to declare the language of the document so that is something we should do.
Now we're going to go to the HTML tag and we can add what is called an attribute and this is the
lang attribute and I'm going to set it equal to en which is the abbreviation for English in general.
You can supply a dialect like this dash us or I believe the other would be gb but I don't usually
do that so I'm just putting en for English. You might have another language you prefer to put
there and you can find a list of those at the MDN network as well and that's the page where we were
looking for the definition of HTML at the beginning of this tutorial so I will link to MDN the Mozilla
developer network in the description. Now that we've added the language attribute let's go look
at the other errors we had and see what else we need to fix. It says the character encoding was
not declared so we also need to handle that. Let's go back to Visual Studio Code and now inside the
head there is an element called meta. Earlier I said the head stores metadata let me keep it all
lowercase here and here we can set what is called the character set attribute inside of a meta
element and from here I'll put UTF-8 which is the standard for all web pages that I have worked on.
There are other character sets but this is the typical value you would see in there so I'm going
to save this and in the future we'll cover more meta tag values that we'll have inside of the head.
Now let's go back and look at that last error that we got from the validation service and that said
start tag seen without seeing a doc type first expected and it shows you exactly what it wants
doc type HTML and that is a document type declaration that should be on the very first
line of your page. So let's go back to our HTML file go to the very top and we'll press return
and we'll paste in exactly what they had there. So you see once again it starts with the less
than and the greater than symbol but this is not really an HTML element or tag this is just a doc
type declaration that you should have in every HTML file at the very beginning. So now I'll put
that in and save as well. Let's look at the validator first and let's choose the file again
and now I've selected the index.html to upload with our changes and we'll click check
document checking completed no errors or warnings so our document is just fine.
Let's go to the tab with our page and let's reload the page and once we reloaded everything
looked great so we've got hello world this is my first web page and we still have my first web
page in the tab at the top for the title and we have passed all validation checks. Let's move on
to what else might go inside of our head element and remember everything inside of the head element
is not seen on the web page and with that said I've dragged the visual studio code window to a
little smaller size on the left and chrome to a little smaller size on the right but I'm just
going to expand visual studio code for now because anything we change inside of the head element will
not be seen on the web page anyway so I'll click the expand button and we'll just see our code.
Now I had mentioned that we could store more metadata inside of the head element and that is
definitely some of what we see so let's add a couple of typical meta tags that have metadata
that you would commonly see the first being for the author of the page so we'll say name the
attribute name is equal to author because that's what type of meta tag this will be and then we'll
have a content attribute and this is where you can put your name I'll put my name for now since
I'm the author of the page and then let's add another meta tag and let's give it a name as well
and here we'll put a description this will describe the web page in a little bit more
detail than possibly the title would so here we can put more of a sentence and once again we need
the content attribute to do that let's say this page contains all the things I am learning
how if I could spell how to and it looks like I'm extending the page so in visual studio code
I'm going to press alt z in windows to make sure the text continues to wrap and then I'll say all
the things I am or I am learning how to create as I learn html there we go now after that of course
you still need to close the meta tag and control s to save and again I got the words to wrap let's
go to the view menu if you scroll all the way down you can see word wrap is alt z it may be
something different if you're on mac or linux so you might want to check the view menu under word
wrap if you want your words to wrap and not just extend forever to the right here now we've added
more description about our page this information could be picked up in a search engine or some
other service that wants to learn more about our web page however let's go ahead and put something
in the head where we will notice the change when we go back to the browser and that is to add what
is called a fav icon and we can do that with a link element let me use lowercase once again
and inside of the link element we'll have several attributes one is the rel which stands for relate
or relation how does this relate to the web page and here we're going to provide an icon after that
we need an href this refers back to html that stands for hypertext this is a hypertext reference
so we're referencing a resource and here we're going to reference a file that i have now put
inside of our folder that is called html5.png and if i click the file explorer over here
you can see i've now added an image file that's a.png file html5.png and you can download this
image from the resources and you can see it's a small little icon for the html5 logo so i'll
close that i'm going to click the file browser to have that disappear again so we see this
then we have one more attribute to add and that is the type what type of resource is this and
here we'll say image slash x dash icon and now we can save this and i'm going to go ahead and
minimize the code window and now if we look at our web page in the browser notice we have an icon
up here my first web page now has our little fav icon beside the title and that's what we added
here in the head by adding the fav icon with a link element now we won't add any more here today
but this is the same area where we would link to css files and even javascript files and other
resources that we pull in from the web so the head is a very important part of the page even though
we don't see the content of the head inside the body of the page and i said we wouldn't link to
anything else here today but since we do have this default css to make our page a dark mode if you
added this and once again this was optional if you prefer the white page with dark text you didn't
need to add this and we had this style element here to hold the css in the head but that's not
usually where you would find it for a page so let's go ahead and do that i'll expand visual studio
code again click the file explorer and over here inside the file tree i want to create a new file
i'm going to call this main dot css and i have an empty css file all we need to do now is go back
to the index select the css that we put here for the html on the body not the style tags just
select the css that's between the style tags i'm going to press ctrl x to cut it out of the page
go to the css file and ctrl v to paste it into the css file ctrl s to save that file now back
in the html i'm going to remove the style element and i'm going to add another link and here for
the rel not ref but rel we have a style sheet because we're adding a css style sheet our href
will now point to our css main dot css specifically and our type which isn't actually required anymore
but since we have it let's go ahead and add text slash css but our browser should know what it is
even if we didn't add that at this point because that's really the only type of style sheet there
is is a css now that we've made these changes let's save the file and let's go ahead and click
the button again to make our code shrink back down and look at our page we can reload just to
make sure it has reloaded and everything looks the same that's because we are pulling in our code
i'm going to go ahead and hide the file tree here we are pulling in our css code using our link tag
inside of the head element now finally i'm going to create an error on purpose by deleting the
greater than symbol at the end of this link tag and saving the file with control s now why would
i create an error on purpose because we want to validate our file again and this will let us know
that yes we've got the right file and we expect one error there you don't of course have to create
an error on purpose but that's what i'm doing to make sure i'm selecting the correct file out of
the correct lesson folder because i'm in lesson two now you might be working on the same file
we started with there's the css file and the image file i'll select the index.html and check
and i should have at least one if not more errors because of that yes i created several errors on
the page just by leaving out that one closing greater than symbol for the link tag so now if
i save again visual studio code formats are code correctly instead of trying to pull the closing
head tag up here and i'm going to go ahead and reload or re-upload the file to check it so we
choose index.html and now i'll click check and document checking completed no errors or warnings
to show so just by missing one little thing in our page we could have a whole list of errors
so follow the prompts from visual studio code notice how if i leave that out here in my theme
this turns red or pink it doesn't look quite right visual studio code wants to format it differently
if i save the file and it pulls that up here instead of putting the closing tag there's several
cues to show you that you have an error in the file and so follow those prompts in visual studio
code and then remember to always validate your page and we always do that at validator.w3.org
i'll get rid of everything at the end of that and here you can pull it up and then we choose file
upload let's look at the basics of creating text content on a web page now web pages are a lot like
essays or even a newspaper where they have headings and usually paragraphs of text
or at least a sentence or two of text describing something afterwards so we see our paragraph
element here and our h1 heading here much of the text content on a web page will be made up of
headings and paragraphs now headings have a hierarchy and that means we'll start out with
only one h1 on the page and each page should only have one h1 but after that we can have sub topics
so here i'm going to press shift alt and the down arrow again i'm using windows it may be
different for you on macro linux but i just copied a line down so now i have two h1s but i'm going
to change this by typing h2 over that h1 and notice how the ending tag immediately changed
here in visual studio code as well so that's helpful now this is a sub topic for the page
so imagine this being the title of your essay or the big headline in the newspaper and then
we have sub topics so for h2 i'm going to type something different let's go with i'm ready to
learn html and now we can have a paragraph about that and so we do at least we have a sentence
this is my first web page now i'm going to highlight this subheading h2 and the paragraph
and once again i'm going to press shift alt and the down arrow and it copies both lines down
for me and i'll add an extra blank line here and i'm going to change this second h2 into an h3
now we i'll use lowercase there we go now we could have more than one h2 on the page but i
wanted to show how you could have a sub topic under our sub topic so we have the title for our essay
and then we have an area of discussion that we've added an h2 as the heading for and now under this
area of discussion we could have further sub topics and this is how we now have an h3 so now
instead of my first web page or i'm ready to learn html let's change this to my daily schedule
so this will discuss our schedule for learning html and then we can just say something about
i'm going to tell you how or let me tell you how i and i'll just put some dots there for now just
we'll expand on that later if we want to but really what i'm showing is this hierarchy
and it's also important not just visually let me go ahead and save this by pressing ctrl s or
remember you can go to the file menu and choose save visually we see that it's naturally formatted
larger on the page with the h1 than it is the h2 and then the h3 is even smaller than the h2
but we can change all of that with css in the future css will really style how our web page
looks but what is important is we can quickly visually tell the headers apart right now
and when a screen reader or other assistive technology looks at our code then it can
navigate the code through the headers of what is important here the header hierarchy and that's why
it's so important to organize your page the headers actually give semantic meaning saying
this is the main topic this is a subtopic under the main topic and this is a subtopic under
the higher subtopic in the hierarchy so headers do have semantic importance and that means giving
meaning to our content and of course then our paragraphs can just have whatever details we want
to add about those subtopics as well now even though we've created a little separation in our
code when we look at our page we just see line space line space and we don't have a good visual
separation I'm going to add an element that doesn't really provide any semantic meaning but visually
it helps us on the page and that is a horizontal rule element and it's just added like this there
is no closing tag for the horizontal rule and then I'm going to add another one after our final
subtopic discussion here so we can add something else underneath that and so now let's save and
look what the horizontal rule adds to the page now we have lines going across the page and those are
called horizontal rules so we have our main heading and now we have our subtopic and I left
the h3 in here because it's a subtopic of this topic so now we can go ahead and I'm going to
highlight the h2 and the h3 ctrl c to copy come down further on the page and paste and I'll save
just so we can see what happens now we have two different subtopic sections and we still have our
top hello world so you could picture this more like an essay page and of course these could be
paragraphs that have more text or you could picture this more like a newspaper and then we
would have an article here and an article here and are heading at the top this is also a good
time to discuss white space so if I just press the space bar and add all these extra spaces to the
page if I save visual studio code is already going to probably reformat this but what is
important to know when I save you'll see yes it changed and it just went back and only left one
space is web pages or html do not honor all those spaces you might add with a space bar it's called
white space collapsing and so we can space many lines but it won't really be represented on the
page that is not how we add extra space in html so again recognize white space collapsing that it
will not last now something we can do is what's called a line break and that can be inserted
inside a paragraph element so now I'll put let me tell you how and then I'm going to return
remember we don't have to have the opening and closing tags on the same line for an element
we can nest other elements inside of an element so I'm going to put a break and that stands for
line break and then I'll put three dots and I'll say let me tell you how I learn more about web
dev and a period that looks good and now we can put another break and I'll just put three more
dots and say I plan out my schedule and one more line break the three dots of course are not
required it's just what I'm adding here and then I'll say I use resources from MDN which previously
we discussed and when I showed the definition of html we were looking at the Mozilla developer
network and that's what MDN is so now if we save this file you can see we've got line breaks
and we're showing each of these details on separate lines okay let's scroll down and change
some of our second topic now so instead of I'm ready to learn html let's change our second sub
topic to I am let me capitalize that I am also planning a vacation and now we can put some
details about that vacation in the paragraph underneath this subtopic and I'll say I've been
working hard and really need a getaway period and let's see if we want to add anything underneath
that yep let's add one more sentence and what I'm going to do once again is shift alt and the down
arrow and visual studio code will copy that line down so now we can just change the sentence here
and I'll say I live in Kansas so I want to visit a beach Kansas is nowhere near the ocean so that
sounds pretty good so let's save that and now we can see our subtopic here changed and we have a
couple of sentences about planning the vacation now let's change the my daily schedule subtopic
at the h3 to places I'd like to visit and I guess I could capitalize that L on like there we go
places I'd like to visit and now I'll highlight that paragraph and say I've heard good things
about the Caribbean sounds like they have warm water and fun islands to visit okay so now we've
got some extra details here and we can have more than one subtopic here so let's go ahead and do
that again shift alt and the down arrow to copy that and places I want to avoid can be our next
one so places I want to avoid and here we can put anywhere cold no way with an exclamation mark
okay so now we've got some extra detail here in our second area and this will allow me to go ahead
and show you the difference between block level elements and inline elements what we've been
working with here are block level elements notice with every paragraph and every heading
they start on a new line that is a block level element it creates space around it which of course
can be formatted in the future with CSS but it does not allow you to put another paragraph inside
of a header or a paragraph without creating that new line that space so there will be a return
essentially in your content when you're using a block level element but when you use an inline
element that doesn't happen so let's look at a couple of these first of all we can say I've
been working really hard and I've been working hard and really need a getaway let's emphasize
that really need a getaway and one inline element that we can do that with is EM and that stands
for emphasis that provides some semantic meaning once again so now a screen reader or other
assistive technology or are just our browser overall knows we're emphasizing this really
need a getaway so let's save and notice really need a getaway is italicized now we're not using
it for the italicized text again the formatting will come later with CSS but that is just the
natural behavior of using the emphasis element as we wrap our text but it provides that meaning
now what if we really want to emphasize that text it has a strong meaning to us
like our no way here we don't want to go anywhere cold well there is a strong element we can use
for that in here let me grab the ending tag and put it at the end of our no way and now I'll save
and notice it got just a little bit bigger and bolder here as far as the natural formatting of
the strong element but again this is an inline element it's inside the paragraph it did not
create a break in the line it did not create any extra space around it so these are inline level
elements and the other elements such as the header and the paragraph we've been working with
are block level elements another type of content we can add to our page are HTML entities so they
are things that are not really the normal text we would type out what for example if we wanted to
show a less than or a greater than symbol on our page right now HTML interprets those as we're
starting or ending a tag so we can't just easily put one of those on the page likewise there are
some other symbols or remember when I talked about white space collapsing if we need a little bit of
extra space there's an HTML entity for that so I want to indent these three lines with a little
bit of space and I can use the HTML entity oh I still need the closing there here we go
and ampersand is usually what starts out an HTML entity and now I'll type n b s p and a semicolon
notice visual studio code recognizes that right away and if I save I have spaced this line over
just a little bit now I can add more than one of those if I want so I'm going to copy that and I'm
going to add two more and now save and our line is over even a little further so I will go ahead
and select all three of these and I'm going to paste them right after the line break on each line
and save and now we have indented with some extra space all three of these lines with these HTML
entities that create space but as I mentioned there are other HTML entities as well so let's
scroll down here to the bottom of our page and after this last topic let's add another HR
and now we'll type and l t and a semicolon and that stands for less than so if we save
now look we have a less than symbol underneath the final horizontal rule here at the bottom
of the page I'm going to go ahead and copy that and paste two more and then I'm going to add
ampersand copy with a semicolon and that will be the copyright symbol then I'll just put my name
you can put yours and then I'm going to add ampersand gt for greater than and a semicolon and once
again I'll copy that and paste two more now if we save you can see we've got our three less than
symbols we've got a copyright symbol then your name or my name and then three greater than symbols
and we're using HTML entities to create those I'll provide a link to a list of HTML entity codes in
the resources for this tutorial you may have noticed we've got a couple of abbreviations
on our page we have the abbreviation for Kansas which is ks and we also have the acronym or
abbreviation for the Mozilla developer network here on our page so let's go ahead and add another
inline level element and that can help us with our abbreviations and that is ABBR but it doesn't
really do it by itself I'm going to go ahead and select MDN cut it and paste it here in the middle
of the element and this won't really provide anything we also need to add the attribute
title here I can put the full text Mozilla developer network and save and now when we
look at our page it has some dots underneath MDN if we mouse over we get a tooltip that says
Mozilla developer network now it's important to realize this tooltip will not really be
available to screen reader and assistive technology so we don't want anything super important for the
understanding of the meaning of the page to be in there so if we are using abbreviation
it's a nice thing to have but it is really not accessible to all assistive technology so
it's you can't have anything in there that the page really depends on because some of the people
accessing the page may not be able to read or see the information that you provide here inside the
title attribute of the abbreviation element let's go ahead and add that abbreviation element for
Kansas as well so ABBR and then title and I'll spell the state name Kansas and then I can go
ahead and double click on Kansas ctrl x to cut and I'm going to paste it with ctrl v right inside
the element save and now dots are under the ks here on the page and if I mouse over we get a
tooltip that says Kansas let's put another paragraph under places I'd like to visit
and I'll put I can just type p and press tab as well there we go and now I'll type I've heard
good things about going here with a colon and now I'm going to add an address element and we can
put a location inside of this address element and it tells the browser that this is an address
or a specific location so I'm just going to paste this in because you don't need to see me type all
of this and I might easily have a typo here this is Margaritaville Island in Cancun it sounds like
a great place for a vacation notice we've got a line break element after each line except the last
line and if we save this and look at the page you can see how the browser handles this it is
just three lines of text it is all italicized by default and the browser knows that this is an
address and once again so would assistive technology so an address element does provide
some semantic meaning as well to the content within it now before we finish this lesson about
content there's one other thing we can add to our code now we won't see it on the page but it is
important to us and this is an HTML comment and so now you can see Visual Studio Code colored this
differently at least with the theme that I'm using and we can leave a note for ourselves
inside of our code now notice this will not be on the page but I will show you how the public can
see it so you don't want to put anything in here that you don't expect the public to be able to
read I'll put a to do which is a common use and I'll just put add more places so it's a reminder
to me to add more places to the list of places I want to avoid and we save that and it doesn't
show on the page it's just a reminder in the code or a note to yourself inside of the code
but I will show you how the public can see this if we right click and choose inspect that works
or you can also press ctrl u either way will show your source code now notice we've got a comment in
here that says add more places it's not visible on the web page itself but it is visible in the
source code again you can press ctrl u to view this now notice live server also injected a comment
here and it injected some javascript so when we look at the overall source code of what is live
we're seeing more than we even had but this is a comment once again that is not seen on the page
and live server is using a script element that we do not see on the page either and that can contain
javascript for example so just to let you know if you leave a note for yourself it can be viewed
by others and finally now that we've added all of this html content to our page we once again should
go to the validator markup validation service from w3c to check our file to see if it is valid html
or if we have any mistakes choose validate by file upload and then click choose file I'm going to
have to probably go to a different folder from the one that I checked last so I'll go to html course
lesson three which is the file we are working with choose my index.html and open that here with
the validator now it has the index.html file uploaded and we can click check and we'll see if
we have valid html so this is valid it's green document checking completed no errors or warnings
to show if you have errors or warnings it should point out exactly where that error is and you can
fix that in your html. Let's look at how to create lists on a web page lists are very useful and are
used in many places on the web so we have three different types of lists we're going to create
today ordered lists unordered lists and description lists let's start out with recapping here we've
got visual studio code on the left and I've got the head element collapsed so we had meta details
inside of there we can collapse that by clicking on the arrow by the line and you see between lines
between four and eleven are now collapsed so we're working inside of the body element to add content
to the page and this is visual studio code and I'm running the live server extension you can see
down here it says port 5500 click to close server if you've installed the live server extension
it may say click to launch or something like that which would actually launch your web page
for you because that's how you want to view it in a development environment you don't want to
just go to file and open the file in your browser you want to have that live server running that
simulates a web server if you're not familiar with the live server extension you can click on
the extensions logo here and instead of searching for prettier that I have in there you can search
for live server and you can install that live server extension by writwick day right here
okay so we've recapped all of that here's the file tree with our files I'm going to hide that by
clicking the file explorer here so we can see more of our code and we will add lists to our web page
today so I'll scroll down to under the subtopic of my daily schedule and notice how we had these
line breaks and spaces here well we're going to replace these so I'm highlighting the first one
and then I'm going to press ctrl d that highlights the next one and ctrl d again now it has
highlighted all three of those and instead of this line break I'm going to type li and press tab
that adds a list item but we haven't enclosed this in a list yet and we definitely don't need
the closing list items here so once again ctrl d ctrl d so all three of these will be list items
but they need to be inside of a list too so let's make this an ordered list by starting out with an
o l and I'll press tab and we got the closing o l tag as well that stands for ordered list
as you might expect and I'm going to actually put the o l down here after the paragraph tag
the closing paragraph tag and I'm going to cut with ctrl x or you could retype if you want to
and I pasted the closing paragraph tag right after the end of let me tell you how so this
is a shortened paragraph now and the list will not be inside of the paragraph and now we have
our ordered list but that also needs closing li tag so I'm going to type the less than symbol
and a slash and visual studio code instantly filled in the closing the rest of what is needed
there and I'll do that again for the second one and then I'll do that here for the last one and
notice we do have the abbreviation still nested inside of the list item here so now I'm going
to press ctrl s and save and visual studio code reformatted that just a little for me
but look at our page now that we've added this list it's an ordered list and it is numbered
that means it's in order numerical order one two and three notice these are not this text is not
enclosed inside of a paragraph element so it's not creating that extra space that a paragraph
element does they're stacked right on top of each other there's still a little bit of space
but not like we have between our paragraphs so that is an ordered list we start out with the
ordered list element and then the list items go inside it and each list item is starting and then
ending with the li now let's scroll down and look at our vacation area says I'm also planning a
vacation and we've got a places I would like to visit area so after that let's go ahead and add
a ul which as you might guess stands for unordered list and we'll go ahead and cut that closing tag
and I want to put it after the address here at the bottom so this will be our full list now we
need to declare list items here in this instance I'm going to go ahead and keep the paragraph tags
inside each list item so we created an li there and I'll use ctrl x to cut and close that first
list item here for the first paragraph I'll do something similar here got an li but the closing
one is going to be in a different spot because our list item can have these tags nested within
it just like we nested the paragraph here I'm going to go ahead and nest the paragraph and the
address inside of the list item here and so now if I save and visual studio code reformatted my code
for me but notice here's the beginning of the list item and we have the end way down here after the
address so let's look at what this unordered list looks like on our page and you can see instead of
numbers it has dots it does have the extra space created by the paragraph tags and the address
element still has the content that it had before and still formatted the same but notice our ordered
list and our unordered list are both indented compared to being over here flushed to the left
with everything else we had like they were before so similar in formatting from an ordered list to
an unordered list and also realize that the really the only difference is the bullet point here in an
unordered list versus the number in an ordered list the extra spaces were caused by the paragraph
element inside of these unordered list items and we did not use a paragraph element on these ordered
list items so the list itself and the list items did not create the extra space that was created
by the paragraph elements now let's scroll our page we've got enough content we need to make sure
we're visiting the very bottom here we want to add more under place I want to avoid and I'm going
to change that to places I want to avoid and let's go ahead and remove our paragraph that says
anywhere cold no way and let's add a description list here so a description list as you might get
starts with dl now inside the description list there are two different types of elements instead
of just an li like we had in our other lists for a list item we have a description term
and this description term could be the place we want to talk about so let's say the north pole
and now for the description term we need to also have description details so that's dd and here I
can put I here this is now let's go ahead and put our strong emphasis back here and I'll put cold
and then our exclamation mark so we have put a strong emphasis on cold and now I'll create
an extra line here just to space these apart another dt I'll put the south pole and then
dd for the details description details and I'll say this is also cold and let's add one more
description term this will be mountain tops and dd for description details and these if I expel
these these are also cold now if we save let's scroll just a little bit more so we can see all
of our content here you can see our description list has a different format than the ordered list
and the unordered list our description term is to the left and then the description details are
indented to the right but here is our full list of the north pole south pole and mountain tops
we want to avoid all of these places when we go on our vacation with these new lists now added to
our file let's go ahead and create an error on purpose just to see if we have an error in our
page when we check it at our validator.w3.org and here I'm going to choose file upload
and I may have to switch folders let's see no I'm in the right one so I'll just choose index.3
I think we're on lesson four and I forgot to change the file but I'll do that to make sure
that the github repo with all the source code is correct so let's go ahead and check this file
and yes we have some errors because we created one specifically let's see if that's our only error
as we have noted in the past one error can create a cascade or a lot of errors so now I've formatted
this correctly let's go ahead and load our file back up so we'll choose file
we'll choose that index.html file again and click check now everything is okay document checking
complete no errors or warnings to show so realize if you have an error it could just be one small
syntax error that creates a cascade of errors when we're checking but this is a great way to
learn and of course look at the details of the code and it's always a good idea to validate your
code after you write it to make sure you don't have any syntax errors let's move on to creating
links on our web page hypertext is the ht in html and it's what links together everything on the web
it's really what makes the web work so well think about spider-man or really any type of spider
that's throwing out strands of web and linking things together that's essentially what we're
doing when we create hypertext links we're linking the web together now as we say link there can be
some confusion because notice here in visual studio code on the left that i've got link tags
that we created in the head part of the page that's from lines 4 to 11 and these link tags
are pulling in resources from other parts of the web whether it's something we have on our server
with our web page like this fav icon or we could pull in something from another part of the web
like a font from google fonts and things like that which we haven't done yet but it's possible
with the link tag but that's not what we use to link pages to each other i'm going to collapse
this head section by clicking on the arrow over here by number four so we have a little more room
and now we're looking at the body area in visual studio code by the way i'm running the live server
extension and have our page from our starter code that's available for download at the github link
in the description and i'm running that with the live server you can see it running here it says
click to close the server shows port 5500 okay in visual studio code let's scroll down a little bit
and let's add what is called an anchor tag that will create a link to another page on the web
so in our list where it says let me tell you how and we're talking about the different things we
do to learn web development we have an abbreviation for the mozilla developer network maybe this would
be a good place to go ahead and link to the mozilla developer network and we can insert a link
around this mdn abbreviation inside the inline element that is the abbreviation element so i'm
going to press enter here to start a new line now i'll just type a and this is well i guess
because it's followed by mdn it's not doing it so i'll start out with the less than sign and then
a and this is the anchor tag that i'm starting but by itself if we just put the anchor tag
while you can do that by itself it will not link to anything it needs a specific attribute
that tells it where to go so i'm going to press enter here and we have it surrounded
by this anchor tag we need to add the href attribute and now we're going to reference an
address on the web so this is where we would put that address in over here in the chrome browser
i have the mozilla developer network open we can see up here at the top it's developer.mozilla.org
and then there's a slash after that that gives the specific language for the site i believe
it will default to the browser choice i'm going to remove that part go ahead and select the rest
and now that i have copied that with ctrl c i'm going to click here inside of visual studio code
and put that address right inside the href attribute now i am wrapping the code down
to another line so you can see it all it doesn't go off the screen i could expand visual studio
code here and now you can see the full address without that line wrapping so we're linking to
the developer.mozilla.org website with this link and we can save this and now i'm going to go ahead
and bring visual studio code back to the size i had it the code lines will wrap but if we look at
our code or our page in chrome that should have now updated because we're using live server
you can see we have a link and it turned purple it's a little hard for me to see right now but
we can change that color in just a little bit but that purple means a visited link if you have not
visited that site it's probably more like a royal blue or a bright blue color and that means it's
not visited yet and those are the default colors for links but something about this link that we
need to acknowledge this is the full address to that website and it's a specific address
this is what you would call an absolute reference this has the full address for the web page to
where we're going but when we link to something that's already on the same server as our page
where we're hosting our website then let's go ahead and expand this head section again
notice we're not giving an absolute reference we're giving what's called a relative reference
right now we don't even have a slash here because we know this html5.png file is in the same folder
as our index.html file and the same with this main.css file it's in the same folder we don't even
need to provide a slash it's not in another folder even so but it is a relative reference
and that's the difference so we have an absolute reference here to a place on the web and then we
can provide a relative reference to something that's on the same server that we're on so now
let's go ahead and create a relative reference to another page and i'll scroll down to do this we
haven't created the page yet we'll do that next but if you have your name here here at the bottom
i have my name where we have the copyright symbol and in chrome i can scroll down and we can see
this at the very bottom let's go ahead and link with a relative reference so i create that anchor
tag that a tag and then href and equals and let's link to about.html and notice i'm putting quotes
around that file name just like i did for the full address in the absolute reference above
and now i want to put my name of course between the opening and closing anchor tag and now that
will link this to the about page that we haven't created yet i'll save and notice now this is that
bright blue or dark blue that i was mentioning earlier a link that has not been visited
this page doesn't even exist yet so we need to create this page if you don't have the file
explorer open in the top left of visual studio code you can click that and you'll see the files
that we have here in the file tree what i want you to do is click on the new file icon name this page
about.html now this is a good place to go ahead and pause the video you can click on the file
explorer tree over here the file explorer to hide the tree if you need more room but go ahead and
create an about page you know everything we've already learned from the index.html page so what
i want you to do is pause the video create your own about.html and then come back and i will create
one with you okay i hope that went well for you i'm going to help you create an about.html page
now or you can watch how i do it and compare to what you did now i've been doing this for a long
time and i'm going to take a few shortcuts so you don't have to see me type everything out i'm at
the index.html page i'm going to press ctrl a to select everything then ctrl c to copy everything
click the about.html page again and i'm going to paste everything in with ctrl v now as you're
learning how to do this i think it's important that you type everything but i don't want to take
up your time and by having you watch me type everything out so i'm just going to make some
changes here the doc type is the same the html elements the same and of course we have a head
section the meta tag for the character sets the same the author is the same now this description
meta tag right here on line seven that could be just a little different i'm also going to press
alt z to get this page to wrap lines that are longer so now you can see line seven wraps down
to a second line here and we see the space to the left now in this description i can change this
just a little bit and i'm going to say hi i'm dave gray this page is about me so we've given
an accurate description for the page now and instead of my first web page in the title i'm
just going to call it about me in the title and now we still can use this same fav icon and we're
going to use the same style sheet so this page will look like the other page as far as the styles
and now we can change the heading for the page and here i'm just going to say hi i'm dave gray
after that i'm going to eliminate most of what we see here on the page so i'm going to highlight
everything from line 17 all the way down to 63 i pressed shift and i clicked on my mouse there
and i've selected all of that specifically and now you can see we're left with the horizontal
rules and the space in between and so now i'm just going to put a paragraph that's not really
about me i'm just going to create some lorem text and i can do that with a p element try lorem
times one i just want one paragraph we'll click that there we go one paragraph of information
so it's still kind of formatted that strange i'm going to go ahead and enter before and after there
we go and now we've got that single paragraph here anyway this is a basic about.html and we
have linked to it so now let's downsize visual studio code back here with the button you see
right here the square not minimized but downsized it's not maximized either and now our link to the
about.html should work so i'm going to click that link and here we're on the about page and now
notice my name is this dark purple again so we have gone to the about page that we just created
says about me here in the top tab i'm going to click the back button to go back to the original
home page here now back on the home page there is a third type of link that we can create and this
is a link to an area on the same page on the page we're already on we can create shortcuts to
different areas of the page so we've had our absolute references we've had our relative
references and now this is what i would call an internal reference or it's an anchor link
directly to a portion of the page that we want to go to in order to do this we're going to add
just a little bit more to our page so i want to click on the index.html there we are going to go
ahead and collapse the head again and we've got a couple of topic areas besides our big hello world
at the top so we've got the part where we're ready to learn html and we've got the part that
we're discussing planning a vacation so we're going to organize this into sections and there
is a semantic html element called section so i'm going to type the word section press tab and then
i'm going to highlight the closing tag of the section ctrl x to go ahead and cut that out
i'll come down here before the horizontal rule we used as a divider and i'll paste that closing
section tag in and if i save yes we've got some auto formatting there so now we have our section
separated and we've got horizontal rules in between i'll go ahead and add a space between each of
those i'm going to do the same thing for the vacation planning area so type section press tab
go ahead and highlight the closing tag ctrl x scroll down to the bottom where we're finished
discussing the vacations and go ahead and paste in that section now i'll save once again took
advantage of the auto formatting and we'll leave a space of course before the section here between
the horizontal rule and the section and the same at the end just so we can see it a little better
after the closing section tag we have a space so now we've created semantic html sections
and that's not all we need we also need to give these sections an id attribute so i'm just going
to give the first id value for the i'm ready to learn html area an id of html and then in the next
section i'm going to give an id attribute and that value is going to be vacation and once again
control s to save or you can go to the file menu and choose save that way as well now that we've
done that we still haven't created the links but we have created the destination for each of the
links that we want to create so now let's create one more semantic html element and to do that
after our hello world heading i'll go ahead and press enter to come down a couple of lines
type hr for one more horizontal rule and now between the horizontal rules i'm going to type
nav and this is a semantic html element it says we're creating a navigation area inside the nav
i'm going to type ul we learned how to create unordered lists already and so now we've added
an unordered list and now we can add list items and the first list item that we're going to create
is a link and there it absolutely after i pressed a and tab it knew we needed the href in visual
studio code so now it's waiting for me to fill in this href now to link to our html section here on
the page we need to add the hashtag and then the id value so there's html and so now we can put learn
html for this link and then let's go ahead and add one more lowercase press tab and now hashtag
vacation and we'll put here planning a vacation as a matter of fact let's change this from learn html
to learning html and now at the top instead of hello world i'm going to put my goals for
the year and now we have my goals for the year at the top and we've got learning html and planning
a vacation but i put them both in the same list item and that's not what we want so i'm going to
go ahead and highlight planning a vacation press control x to cut that out and now let's put it
in its own list item so li press tab we've got a new list item and we can paste that planning a
vacation if we save that looks much better on our page even though the blue isn't looking great on
the darker background we'll still change that in the future so now if we click learning html on
the page it goes ahead and scrolls the page directly up to the i'm ready to learn html
section we can click back and we go back to where we were and now if we click planning a vacation
it doesn't take us all the way to the planning a vacation area because there's no more content
there's no more space it can't scroll any higher but it's scrolled as far as it possibly could to
take us to that area and once again we can press the back button to go back and that dark purple
is not looking too well so we're going to need to change those colors very soon before we change
any colors though let's scroll down and create one more link that's an internal link on our
same page here just to another area of the page so at the very bottom underneath our name and the
link to the about page let's go ahead and return and add one more line here and this will be a
paragraph so we can press p and tab inside the paragraph let's start an anchor tag and there has
the href attribute and let's just link to the hashtag itself now what we want to put in here
for text is back to top and we can save now if we scroll down in our page here we'll see the back to
top link and if i click it it loads the page and takes us back to the top it's worth noting what
we have up here in the address bar of course live server gives us our ip address which is our own
computer 127.0.0.1 nobody else on the web can see what you're seeing this is just on your computer
and then you've got a colon and the port number 5500 where live server is serving your page
and we've got our index.html file then notice you've got the hashtag after that we could actually
remove the index.html and the index page will still show by default just like you see right here
and now once again if we click learning html notice in the address we get the hashtag html
when we click back it disappears if we click planning a vacation we get the hashtag vacation
in the address bar and if we click back it disappears in previous tutorials i had mentioned
switching the theme over to this dark mode that's easier on my eyes was entirely optionable so
if you're still using a white background with black lettering probably the purple and blue
links look just fine to you and you could just leave it that way if you have switched to the dark
mode theme that i have provided with some basic css already let's go ahead and make those changes
so the links look better as well so we're here in the main.css file now in the file explorer
so we're just going to change the color of our anchor tag and i'll switch that color to a color
named alice blue after that i also want to change what the link looks like when it's been visited
right now it's that purple color so i'm going to change that color to a light gray and there's
also another thing that we can change and that is when you hover over the link or when the link is
active and then i'm just going to change that color to hashtag ee not three ee there we go
and save that and so now it's changed the color of our links you can see this is the light gray
we visited these links but when i hover over it gets a little lighter and so that looks good i
think we visited every link here no we haven't visited back to the top yet so you can even see
the alice blue color right here and let's go ahead and visit back to the top and now if we go back
you can see it's a little darker until i hover over it so we've just changed those colors we're
not really covering css yet we eventually will after we get through all of the html
but just for now if you want those of course these will be downloadable as well in the source code
let's go back to the index.html file and let's hide this file explorer by clicking on the icon
in the top left this is a good spot to talk about some link naming conventions and things you don't
want to do so for now i'm just going to use this link at the very bottom that has my name as an
example and one thing you wouldn't want to do is be instead of my name just put in the file text
like this or what would be worse would be a full url like www.google.com slash about.html
and if i save this of course that's not to google that's just ugly and of course you don't need all
of that you can pair that down to just actually a short description of what is there you don't
really want the full url there so i'll put this back to my name and there we go and another thing
you really don't want to do is say this links to info about because really that's redundant
so if i save that and we go this links to info about and i didn't have a space there i guess but
either way saying this links to is really redundant just saying this is a link a screen
reader knows it's a link you already know it's a link when you see something underlined like that
so you don't need to say this links to or this is a link about that's just unnecessary you also
want to keep your link text as short as possible so imagine if i had that same sentence before
this links to information about dave gray and you just put the whole sentence in the link
that's way too long just keep it to the exact topic so if the page is about you as in our about
page just put your name in there for the link you don't want a whole sentence about that
and now the very worst one of all really would be to say something to learn more about me
comma and then instead of having your name right here for the text you put click here we've
probably all seen a link on the web that says click here that has no description whatsoever
for what's on the following page that's not good for the context of what you're linking to
it's not good for a screen reader as it tries to get context from what the link says
so really a link that says click here and of course you can imagine there could be several
links that say click here all on the same page linking to different things and that's just
confusing so you always want to avoid something like that that says click here so once again i'll
remove all of this and we'll just go back and we'll put our name here at this link but i hope
those pointers give you some guidelines about namings just keep it short and of course say
what is on the following page a very brief description not a full sentence and definitely
not something generic like click here okay i'm going to save the index.html and we're going to
go back to the about.html page and we'll add a few more link types so we've got a section that we're
really saying this is about me let's just add one more area here so we can add another horizontal
rule press tab and now let's add an unordered list and inside this unordered list we'll have
list items and this first list item should be a download so we have a favicon file that we can
offer for download so let's say download n and then i'll give the anchor tag so a href equals
and now let's link to that favicon file that we have so that would be html5.png
and now inside of this we can put our html5 favicon text but this won't allow us to download
the file yet we need to add the download attribute and now this is a download link
so if we save this and we go ahead go back to the top over here in chrome and well i guess not back
to the top we need to go ahead and click your name or my name whatever you've got on your page
and that takes us to the about page and now we have download an html5 icon and remember this
icon is in our folder over here as i click the file explorer so we've got html5.png
and that's what we're going to download so if we click this link
we instantly get a download of that file so that is a download link
now let's add another type of link so add another list item here and inside our list
item now let's say contact me at and now let's go ahead and do another anchor tag with the href
and we can add an email link even though these are not advised and i should say before we add
this these are not advised because there are so many spiders out there that crawl the web really
search spiders if you will and what they do could harvest these email addresses and so these have
kind of become a thing of the past most people add a contact form which we'll talk about forms
in the future instead of just putting their email address directly in the page to be harvested but
to add an email link you start with mail2 and after that you would just have your email address
so i'll just put random at email.com and if that's your email email address i'm sorry
but it seems random to me and then i can just put my email address which would complete the
sentence rather than actually typing the email address there as well so i like something like
that as far as being descriptive contact me at my email address and that's what the link is the
link is describing your email address okay then there's one other type of link we can have oh
let me save that by the way and if you click this link that says my email address it would ask you
what type of email client you want to open these types of links with is what it should do at least
okay the next link type that we have in our list item will be dialing a telephone number so now
i'll say oops spell it right dial and now let's put our anchor tag with the href and we start out
with TEL for the telephone number and you can experiment with this many examples i've seen
add the plus symbol and i've also got it to work without the plus symbol so i'll put the plus
symbol here in the united states most phone numbers are 10 digits so i would have like one
two three would be the first set of digits then four five six and the last set of digits seven
eight nine zero something like that and that is a telephone link so i could say dial and then i
could just put my phone number just like i did with my email address and now especially on a
mobile phone if this was a mobile website this would be very handy you could tap this and it
should open up the dialer if i click this link now in chrome it wants to make a call it's asking me
how to do it and pick an app to do it because i'm here on my laptop but on a mobile device this
would probably open up the dialer right away now let's look at one more type of attribute here so
i'm just going to put one more list item inside that one more anchor tag with the href attribute
and we're going to link directly to google so we need an absolute reference this would be
https colon slash slash www.google.com and we can put the slash if we want to as well
and this is an absolute reference but the attribute oh and i haven't really put in any
text let's go ahead and just put google uh because we're not really adding any extra context to this
so the attribute that we need to consider that we haven't used yet is target and what i want to do
is have this open in a new tab so i'm going to use quotes then you put underscore blank and save
and now we have a link to google so let me maybe add a little context here i'll put open google
and a new tab period save that and now we've got our link to google if we click this
we opened up a new tab and i don't have internet right now i guess i need to check my connection
internet's back up and running let's click this link again and there's google so we've opened it
in a new tab and all is well so i'll go ahead and close that there's the one that didn't work
and now we're back to our page now there's one more type of link i want to add before we finish
today let's scroll down in our about.html and underneath our copyright line let's go ahead
and press enter add a paragraph and inside here we'll add the link that we want to add so type
a for anchor and now the href is just going to have a slash value what this does is link back
to the root of our website and that is our index.html it's the page that loads by default remember i
had said we don't even have to have the index.html up here in the address it's just the slash after
the ip address and the port here on our local server and if we had a domain name like google.com
well then the slash would essentially be the home it doesn't have anything else after the slash it
loads a page by default so that's the same thing we're doing for our website so here we can just put
back to home and save this and now we have a link that will take us back to our index page so let's
click this link and we're back to our index.html but notice in the web address it doesn't even have
the index.html up here it doesn't need that because it loads this page by default this is the first
page of your website now that we've made all of these changes to our web page and we've actually
added a second web page let's go to validator.w3.org and validate make sure that we don't have any
errors in our index.html and our about.html we're going to choose validate by file upload
and choose file and for me i'm going to have to go into my html tutorials folder click html course
and i'm in the zero five lesson here so index.html open the file and check
and document checking complete no errors or warnings to show now we want to do the same thing
for the about.html and let's check that as well and once again document checking completed no
errors or warnings to show if you have errors or warnings of course follow up on what it shows you
here in the validator and i hope you've learned a lot about the different kinds of links you can
create in your html files let's look at adding images to our web page until now we've only worked
with text but html supports multimedia and images are a big part of that so what we want to do is
go to visual studio code that i have here on the left and i have our project running here on the
right and we're using live server for that so the live server has launched down here and you can
click to close the server or open the server if you don't have the live server extensions search
for that here in the extensions find live server and that should pull up by ritwick day and you
just want to install that and it can launch your page for you okay going back to what we need we
have clicked on the file explorer in visual studio code and we need to create a folder to hold our
image files so i'll type img to name this folder and it is a common practice to keep your images
for your web page or web pages in a separate folder as you organize your project now that we've
got that i'm going to grab some images and paste those in so we can work with them you'll be able
to download these images from the files and resources that i share in the description
however at the end of this tutorial i'm also going to go over some resources where you can download
your own images that are free for use so now inside this image folder i'm just going to right click
and choose paste and paste these images in and let's look at what we've got i can click on the
vacation image and i get this vacation image here and notice at the bottom we can see the size of
the image it's 400 by 267 those are pixels we can look at this html logo that we're going to use
it's 300 by 300 and we've got an image of the caribbean as well and it's 400 by 225 so i'm
going to collapse this now and we're going to use those in our html code so now i'll click on the
file explorer to hide the file tree and this all starts with the image tag so let's scroll down in
our html to where we want to insert our first image in our page i'm going to put it right below
the paragraph that says this is my first web page in the i'm ready to learn html section
okay let's start by typing img and pressing tab and then visual studio code will help us with
that imit abbreviation and it will automatically fill out the rest of the image element now notice
the image element doesn't have a closing element like we see here with a heading or we see here
with a paragraph sometimes you will see it with a slash like that at the end which means it's self
closing html does not require that i should say html5 does not require that however if you are
using this in the future in something like react it may require that so that's just something to be
aware of right now i won't put that in because html5 does not require it and that's what we're
focusing on okay notice the image element has a source attribute and an alt attribute automatically
the source attribute tells html where to grab the image we want so we start by typing the folder
name that we created and now we see the folder here image slash and i can click on that and then it
provides us the names of the images that we have well we want the html logo that i saved so i'll
just click on that and there is the full relative path to our image it's in the same project here
and it's on our local server in this area so we don't need that absolute url that would grab it
from somewhere else on the web so this is once again a relative path to our folder and then to
the image then we have the alt attribute now the alt attribute has a couple of purposes
one is to help assistive technology for those that may not be able to see the image we are
putting on the page the assistive technology like a screen reader will read the description of the
image so let's put html5 logo as the alt text but this also makes this alt text appear on the page
if the image for some reason does not load so first of all let's just save our page and you'll
see the logo now appear on the web page and suddenly our page got much more interesting
it's awesome putting images into our web pages however let's go ahead and change the file name
so that it doesn't find the image and let's see what happens on the page now we have a broken
image icon but notice our alt text appears html5 logo so that is another purpose of the alt
attribute i'll fix that so we get our logo back now there's other attributes that we can and
probably should use with an image so one is title now we've seen the title attribute before
remember the title text that we provide here in the title attribute is not accessible a
screen reader will not read it so this can't be something that is very important that everybody
should know this is text that can complement our image but it's not necessarily required
the page is complete without it but we can add some complementary text here so i'll just put i
am learning html5 it doesn't have to be i don't even need the period really it doesn't have to be
identical to the alt text at all this should be complementary but now if we mouse over the image
we'll see the title pop up that says i am learning html5 and that's complementary a couple of other
attributes that way back in the 1990s these were required however for years these have not been
required but now they're coming back and it's width and height so if we define a width here
and we want to provide the same width of our image now i saved this image with a file name
that tells me or reminds me exactly the width and the height and it's 300 pixels by 300 pixels so
i'll just put 300 if we just provide the width html will remember or shift the image to match
so the aspect ratio stays the same so if i switch this to 200 and save notice it also adjusted the
height of the image however we want to provide both we want to provide the width and the height
and let's provide exactly what they are and i'll tell you why this is making a comeback and why
it is now recommended to provide the width and the height even though we can change this in the
future with css so i'm saying we provide these but yes css may change and override these values
so why do we provide them well it's a little complicated but it's called cumulative layout
shift if you've ever gone to a web page and you were getting ready to click on something and then
you saw the page shift around maybe a pop-up ad appeared or a banner ad and you clicked on
something that you didn't intend to click because the button or the image that you wanted to click
suddenly moved that is cumulative layout shift so we provide the width and the height now to tell
the browser hey this is going to take up some space here and this is how much if we don't provide
that the browser shifts everything once it figures out the size of the image now once again you can
still change the size of the image make it responsive which would adapt to mobile devices
and everything else with css so we really provide this information with the width and the height
just to give the browser an idea of the size and the aspect ratio coming in so it just kind of
prepares itself and that helps just a little bit it is now recommended by google developers that
we do provide the width and the height in the image element with our first image added now let's
scroll down and add a second image to our page and we'll scroll down to our vacation area place
i'd like to visit let's change this to places i'd like to visit and they've got i've heard good
things about the caribbean so this seems like a great place to put an image of a caribbean beach
so once again we'll type our img abbreviation and press tab and then visual studio code helps us
out by providing the image element with the source and alt attributes ready to go so for the source
once again type the name of our folder press slash and now we get the names of the images we have
ready i'm going to choose caribbean and then in the alt area i'm going to type caribbean beach
and now let's save and see what we get on the page when we scroll down because we have to scroll
down a little ways to see it and there is our caribbean beach image so now let's add a title
attribute that's just a little different than our alt attribute just complementary text
and this is i want to visit a caribbean beach and we'll save that now we're getting closer but
remember we should apply the width and the height attributes as well so let's click on the file
explorer because i didn't have the width and the height saved in the name of this jpeg file.jpg
notice the other image we used was a.png there are different image file types and those have
different extensions so now i'll click the explorer up here i'll go back open the image folder
and i'm going to click on the caribbean image now when i do that in visual studio code it shows
the image and at the bottom i can see it is 400 pixels by 225 the first number is the width so
i'm going to close this now click file explorer to hide that so i have a little more room and
now i can say width equals 400 and the height equals 225 and if we save everything should
remain the same we've just provided these extra attributes now i've noticed that this wrapped a
little strange here in visual studio code but know that the width and the height are still part of
the image element that we started right here okay now that we've got that let's go ahead and remove
the n from the jpeg so it will not find the image and make sure our alt text appears yes we've got
a broken image icon but it says caribbean beach and that is our alt text so i'll fix that by
putting the n back in the name spelling it correctly and the image shows up because now
visual studio code can find the file for us okay we had to scroll down to see this image because
our page is long enough that if we scroll to the top we don't see our vacation area anymore
now this bottom of the page here you could call it a crease if it was a newspaper and a lot of
the terminology kind of goes back to newspapers and magazines as we talk about layout and so this
bottom part that defines the line that anything below that we do not see right now that's called
the fold so anything after this area that we can now see is called below the fold so anything below
the fold we have to scroll to see and now we scroll to see this image well there's one more
attribute for this image that i want to talk about and it's the loading attribute and if we
provide loading and we can set it equal to a value and there's two possible values the first one
is eager but we never have to provide this this is the value by default so if we do not provide
the loading attribute the loading attribute is always there and it's just set to eager we just
don't see it but the one that we do need to provide is called lazy and what you want to do
for performance for your web page is for any image that is below the fold that is one you do not
currently see when the page loads you want to set the loading attribute to lazy and that means the
browser will only load that image when it knows it is about to show it when we start to scroll
now firefox the web browser firefox is much easier to demonstrate this in chrome wants to
display the image much earlier so right now this image is close enough to the area that we see
that it will still load this caribbean image automatically that we have here so i need to
create some extra space and i can demonstrate this to you by using something called chrome dev tools
that's available in the browser so let's do that now i'm going to scroll back up above places i'd
like to visit to the hr area the horizontal rule that we have going across right here before the
i am also planning a vacation and i'll type an abbreviation br for a line break and then i'll
put the asterisk for times and i'm going to put 150 this imit abbreviation that visual studio
code supports will insert 150 line breaks into our page there's no way i would want to type all
of those individually but i can do it with this abbreviation so i'll click that and suddenly we
have all of these line breaks if i save and we don't see this change but now there's a lot of
space between the sections and that's what i need to demonstrate this so we've changed the code i'm
going to click the maximize button here in chrome to bring the browser all the way out and now let's
right click and choose inspect and you could also do this with keys and it would be control
shift in the letter i all at once the control key the shift key in the letter i i'm just going to
right click and choose inspect either way we'll open up the dev tools in chrome and now that we're
getting the dev tools open it will automatically open to the elements tab and notice how if i
hover over an area in the elements now it highlights those on the left in the browser
so here i've hovered over my goals for the year and we can see that i can hover over the section
that discusses html and it highlights that section what we want to do though is click
the two greater than symbols here at the top and i'm going to choose the network tab
once it shows the network tab you'll want your disable cache to have the check mark
and that is because browsers know to save images after they've loaded them initially so they can
reload them fast but that is called the cache where it stores the images that's c a c h e
we want to disable that cache so we can demonstrate this also in this area right below the filters you
see all fetch slash x h r j s c s s choose the image all we are interested in right now are the
image files we don't want to see the rest of the files so once you've done all of that we're going
to go ahead and reload the page so i'm going to click the reload icon up here in the browser
and we've reloaded and notice down here we just see the html logo file that's all that has loaded
right now and now as we scroll down as we get close to the caribbean image file we will see
it load because it has the loading attribute set to lazy so only once we get close and i created
a lot of space here so i'm scrolling down and fairly soon it should pop up there it is we don't
see it on the page yet over here but it's getting close so chrome loaded it in preparation for us to
see it but what that really helps is that it did not load the image right when we loaded our page
so that made our page load faster it only loads these images when it thinks it's going to need
them and that is lazy loading so now you can click the x here in the top right to close the dev tools
then i'm going to click the maximize button again to get the browser back to the size we
wanted it i'll drag it down here so we can see everything and then over in visual studio code
i'm going to press ctrl z which is undo you could also go to the edit menu and choose undo but i'll
do ctrl z and get rid of all those line breaks but again if you want to demonstrate that you
can just type in br and then how many of those elements you want and visual studio code will
recognize that so that is a demonstration of a lazy loading technique that helps your pages
load faster imagine if you had a page that had a dozen or 20 or even 50 images you wouldn't want
the page to continue loading until it loaded all of those images so lazy loading is a very
good performance technique especially when you're dealing with lots of images that are below the
fold now let's add a new element to our page and it's something we're going to wrap this image in
so i'll put it underneath the paragraph that says i've heard good things about the Caribbean and
i'm going to type the word figure and i'll press tab because figure is an element now i'll highlight
the closing tag and press ctrl x to cut you can also get these options that i use with the keyboard
shortcuts in the edit menu there's cut copy and paste so it's ctrl x to cut and now at the end
of the image here i'm going to paste which is ctrl v and now i've got the opening and closing
figure tags i'll highlight the image here and just tab it in as i'm used to seeing it so the image
is inside the figure element now this by itself won't do much but it is saying we've got a figure
with an image and we can add a caption and it tells the browser that the caption big caption element
is related to the image which is better than just putting a paragraph underneath it the paragraph
while we could visually see it's probably related to the image if it was right under the image
it's not telling the browser or assistive technology that it is a caption for the image
this spells it out for both the browser and assistive technology that yes what we put in
here is directly related to this image but it doesn't have to be identical to the alt attribute
of the image although it should kind of be a description of the image so i'll put Caribbean
beach getaway here as our fig caption and now it does show up on the page and notice the image has
been indented just a little bit and once again we can change all of the layout of the page and how
everything looks with css in the future but this is just the uh default behavior when we apply a
figure it's indented somewhat so we have an image and the caption now let's go ahead and add our
last image as well and we want to put that underneath margarita island reserve Riviera
Cancun an actual resort in the Mexican Riviera Cancun area so we'll scroll down here and underneath
the address we want to add an image of at least the Cancun area because that's where we're thinking
about going so image and we press the tab button and we get the source and alt attribute again so
let's type img that's the name of our folder and slash and now we've got our vacation image and
that looks good and now we can put in the alt tag the Cancun vacation for our vacation image
and now in the title we can put something like it's five o'clock
somewhere because that's kind of related to margaritaville and jimmy buffet and he's famous
for that saying and it's five o'clock somewhere there's something worth noting about this phrase
we've got single quotations here inside of our double quotations now that's what's possible
if we had used single quotes out here this would not be possible but we can use single quotes
inside of our double quotes so this does work now let's go ahead and save and if we look at the page
right underneath the address for the resort we're thinking about we've got our Caribbean vacation
image and if we mouse over we've got the title it's five o'clock somewhere that looks good but
notice we don't have the space or the indentation that we get from the figure element so let's go
ahead and put a figure element around this image as well so we'll type figure press tab once again
i'm going to highlight the closing tag press control x underneath the image control v to paste
it in and if i save i should get some auto formatting and so now i've got the image indented
inside the figure and let's add a caption here as well remember it's the fig caption element so
i'll press tab and now let's put a Caribbean vacation image so it's not quite the same as
our alt attribute it's not the same as our title attribute but it's a nice description of this
image okay we're not quite finished with our image it's easy to forget some of these attributes
that we might not think about applying right away so one we know we need is the loading because
this will absolutely be below the fold so let's set that to lazy as well and save and now let's
click on the file explorer again in the top left and let's look at our vacation image and find the
dimensions and we can see here at the bottom it's 400 pixels by 267 pixels so now we can close that
out and click on the file explorer to hide that again and let's provide width and height so the
width is equal to 400 and the height is equal to 267 so now we've provided all the correct attributes
that we need for this image and everything looks good here on the page one more thing i want to add
about figure figure is not just for images so let's scroll up here in vs code back to our html area
and we do have our html logo right here underneath this is my first web page we'll scroll back up to
this area here on the page as well and now we can add a figure underneath this image
so i'll type the word figure again and now let's add a fig caption first the fig caption element
needs to either be the first thing inside of a figure or the last thing it can be either or
so here i'm going to type in example of html5 code and that will be our caption so let's save
that much and we see that here but really we have no content inside of our figure yet so let's go
ahead and add some content and i'll add a paragraph which is a block level element we've discussed
that in the past block versus inline and now for the text of the paragraph i want to put that
inside of an inline element that will not create a line break and it's a code element code this
element code helps you actually display code if that's what you want to use you can use other
elements inside of it though so if i want to display html code i can't simply put an h1 element
because then it applies this element to the page we need to go back to what we learned about html
entities to provide the less than sign which is an ampersand lt with a semicolon then i could
type h1 and then ampersand gt with a semicolon for the greater than symbol and now i'll put
hello world with an exclamation mark and then i'll do the less than html entity again and then
a slash h1 and then the ampersand gt semicolon which is greater than and a semicolon and now if
we look at the page we have got an example of some html code printed directly to our web page
so this is another example of how to use a figure element it can contain other content such as a
code sample and you can have a caption at the top just as easily as you can at the bottom of the
figure okay our code for the lesson is complete but i do want to show you some image resources
but before we can do that we need to validate our code with the validator once again so i'm going
to grab this and make it just a little wider so the validator shows up better here remember
we're at validator.w3.org we want to click validate by file upload click choose file make
sure you're in the correct folder once this folder area opens up and i'm in the lesson six folder
and then i'm going to choose the index file that we were working in and choose open and from there
i can choose check and it should check the html it says document checking completed no errors or
warnings to show that's what you want if you do get an error or warning it should tell you what
line it's on in your code and you can refer to visual studio code find the line and fix the
error that it is telling you about so once again validate your code before you finish before
finishing this image lesson i wanted to share some resources that i use now there are many
resources out there so these are just a few and i'm sure you can find others as well first there's
this article that has 21 of the best placeholder image generators using placeholder images is very
common practice when you're laying out a page and you're not sure the images you want to use yet
what you can do is take a url like this from placeholder.com and put it in as the value of the
source attribute in your html image tag and then it will generate a placeholder image until you
find the image you want to put there some of these other image generators actually provide pictures
like the second one on the list called phil murray provides random pictures of the actor bill murray
but it works in the same way you put the url in for the source attribute value in your image tag
and then you will get a picture of bill murray from this image generator okay the next several
sites are just great places to download freely usable images as it says right here these are
licensed for free use it's important to download and use images that you actually have the usage
rights to so this is a good way to do that find them on unsplash.com is my favorite you can also
go to pexels.com as you see here very similar site you can also go to gratisography.com
and this site has unique and kind of funny pictures so that's kind of neat too and you
never know what you'll see on these the next one is pixabay.com very much like the previous ones
i showed you from there i want to suggest some free image software it's called irfan view i've
used this for years it's just really lightweight software easy to use and you can load in an image
and resize it and that's what i usually use it for you can also crop images with it i'll pull
it over here as i have an instance of irfan view open already you can see i've got in this large
picture of the caribbean beach but you can go to the edit menu and you can see different options
that are here such as the crop and of course we'd have to select an area to do it but in the image
menu there is a resize resample and here you can see you've got the dimensions of the image but i
can resize this it's a huge image right now at 5,464 pixels wide i'll take it to say 400 pixels
and it stays in sync so it keeps the aspect ratio and now we're at 225 for the height so you see the
current size and then the new size i'll click okay and it brings it down to a much smaller nicer
size easy to save as well as a new name and a great little software to use from there i also
recommend canva.com now disclosure here there is a paid subscription to use this site however i
believe they have a free account that you can at least get some of the features or try it out so
canva.com is good after you've got your images and even after you have resized your images to
the smaller size that you would probably use on your web page it's also a good idea to drag and
drop them into tinypng.com i believe this also comes up if you type in tinyjpg.com but it will
compress the images and they will still look good but they get a smaller file size so they load to
that web page faster which is always important so all of these resources are great and i will put
links to all of them in the description below documents need organization and our html files
are no different html achieves document organization with semantics in this lesson we're going to
improve our code with the semantic html layout let's get started i've got visual studio code
here on the left with our index.html open and on the right i have got our index html page
displaying and we're using the live server extension for visual studio code to display that
page and you can see it's launched down here you can click the close or open the server you can
search for that extension over here at the extensions icon if you do not have it again
it's the live server extension okay so we're adding semantics to our index html page now we've
already added some so let's highlight what we have done already as we've built this page out over the
lessons the main thing that we have done correctly is add a hierarchy of headers you only want one
h1 per page and this should be an outline much like you would have an outline for an essay
or any type of paper topic you would write so this is your title for the whole page essentially
and from there you can have multiple h2 headers which is one level down in the hierarchy
and they would define sub topics and then beneath that you could have h3 headers if there was a sub
topic of a sub topic and so on and that continues to h6 although you really don't want any more than
about three levels of headings on a page so h1 h2 h3 would be the ideal way to have a page laid out
after that we need to consider some things about semantic html writing semantic html helps us
quickly see or read the different sections in a web page and navigate to those sections now we've
already added a nav element to our page and nav elements are semantic elements so this says
we have a grouping of links here and we can see that on the page with learning html and planning
a vacation we have a grouping of links here that will help us navigate to the rest of the page
we also have an hr which stands for horizontal rule in the past i believe i might have said
these didn't really have a semantic meaning but they do they're currently viewed as semantic
elements and it means that there is a topic change so something is changing and of course
we have a couple of topics on our page and we have horizontal rules between those in the future as
we learn css we may want to remove the horizontal rules we see here that divide our navigation
and our heading for the page and replace those with lines that we can create with css because
we're not really separating topics here although it doesn't hurt to have these horizontal rules
in place at this time and the main thing to convey about semantic html is the word semantic
that means it provides meaning as the nav element says hey this is a navigation area or the h1
element says hey this is a heading we can also get that from other parts of the page we added
section elements that say this is a new section so they provide additional meaning rather than just
a generic divider and we will talk about what a generic divider is later as well now in addition
semantic html makes our pages accessible to screen readers and other assistive technology
and that is very important as we create pages now while we've added some semantic html already
let's add the three big areas that most consider for pages the first is not a head section
but a header for our page now we have a heading which is the title of the page but we can wrap
this in a header element and there can be more than one header element per page however it needs
to follow the heading hierarchy so imagine if we had a social media site now every post whether
it would be a blog post or a post like facebook or instagram every post could have its own header
and it might have a subtitle in that post as well but this is a header now for our full page so this
would be at the top level of our page with the hierarchy here of h1 which is the heading for our
page notice we've also included the navigation inside of our header and we can go ahead and remove
this horizontal rule and i think it will be just fine we don't need the semantic meaning of a
change topic there and i think it's going to look okay without the line as well so let's save this
now and we can see live server updates our page immediately so we can see the change
and really all we see visually is that our horizontal rule is removed however we have
added some extra meaning to our html here now that this is the heading or the header section
for our full page now the next element we want to add is the main element now there can only be
one main element per page and by definition that would make sense you can only have one main area
for content per page and so we'll start here and it's going to include our sections that we've
created so i used control x to cut the closing main element tag and i'll scroll down to where
our second section ends before our area here at the end and i'll paste the closing main element
and save and we can see visual studio code reformatted for us so now we've got the main
element wrapping our two topic areas of vacation and of html so we've added a header and a main
element now one other thing we can add for our page is a footer now just like the header there
can be more than one footer per page and that might be a footer for a blog post or a footer
for a social media post but this is the footer for our entire page in this example once again
control x to cut that closing tag and i'm going to wrap everything we have here at the end in the
footer one other thing i want to add just because i didn't do it before we validated our page
throughout the other lessons and it's not an error it's not a problem but i want to
include this information here about the copyright i want to include that in a paragraph element so
i'm going to make sure that's lowercase what am i getting a capital there we go and then i'm going
to once again cut the closing tag and put it after the content and save it gets reformatted
it really doesn't change the look i just wanted both inside that paragraph and that might help
in the future when we want to format this area as well with css so now our document has been
outlined into three major sections we have a footer a main area and a header and then inside
the header we've already discussed we have a navigation element that is also semantic html
our list is also semantic html we know right away that this is providing a list and this would be
identified by assistive technology as well now there can be more than one nav element per page
so we might have a nav area in the footer footers often have links to other areas of a website now
we've only got a couple of links in our footer and one goes back to the top and the other does go to
our about page however it's not a grouping of links where we would organize if we had several
other things here i might consider a nav and if you do have more than one nav element per page
it's important that they are labeled so assistive technology knows which nav is which and here we
can do that with an attribute called aria-label and then we can set it equal to something that
clearly says what it is like primary navigation and now we have labeled our nav as the primary
navigation area if you did include a heading in the nav element which is not required but if you
did you could link to that so you could have an h2 here and then in the h2 we might put primary
navigation if i can spell it there we go and now let's give this an id
and here we'll give the id the same value primary navigation and then here instead of aria we would
say aria labeled by is the correct attribute here now we're looking at our primary navigation value
and it's saying hey it's labeled by this value that's in the h2 so you can link these together
with an aria labeled by pointing back to the id of a heading however since we're not going to
have an h2 in our nav i'll go ahead and remove that and you can just choose the aria label
attribute and set that equal to primary navigation which is equally accessible to screen readers and
other technologies okay let's scroll down into this main area previously we broke our topics
html and vacation into sections which are semantic html tags however there is a more appropriate
tag now that we kind of have an idea of how our page is laid out because these are areas that
could be on their own maybe they would each have their own page but much like a social media post
or a blog post some type of article you might think there is an article element so i have
highlighted this section and i'm going to type article instead and i believe we'll find that
vs code changes our closing tag immediately yes and it was already changed to article
so instead of a section let's call this an article because it clearly has its own topic
and now let's do the same for our other section based on vacation so we can highlight it
change it to article and we'll verify that the closing tag is also article and yes it is right
here so now we have two articles instead of sections now there is sometimes a debate about
which should be used and it's really not clearly defined if article or section is the proper choice
they would both pass a validator check so really the way i look at it is an article has a clear
topic where a section is more generic you might use a section just to actually create a little
section in your code whereas an article has a clear topic that the area is about so now inside
of the article we could create other articles but now i want to go ahead and add a couple of sections
inside of our html article so as our article begins we've got the heading which is h2 and
it says i'm ready to learn html and then we have a paragraph saying this is my first web page that's
fine let's go ahead and add the section after that point and now once again i'll press tab to
get both the opening and closing tags i'm going to highlight the closing tag control x to copy it
i'm going to bring it down here to just underneath the figure and that's where we'll end this first
section i also want to go ahead and add a subheading here which is an h3 and i'll just make
this html5 as that's what the section is about and now our section has the subheading html5
it has the html5 logo and it has our figure that has our code sample of html5 that all seems
related now let's add another section and this is the my daily schedule section so lowercase again
that's what i prefer and so we'll have section and the closing section tag i will cut that
and i'll put it here at the end of the list before the closing article tag so now we have
two clear sections inside of our article and they both have headings that are h3 so we're
the third tier of the heading with the h1 being the heading for the overall page the h2 being
the heading for the article and then the h3s being the headings for the nested sections
within the article so we're keeping our hierarchy in place underneath the list we can add another
element and just a little more content let's call this an aside this is a semantic element
and if you think about how a web page is laid out oftentimes you think of an aside as the
sidebar to the page but it could also just be another section of complementary text
that is not as important as what's in the main section or article that you are putting it inside
of and that's what we'll do here and then i want to use some other semantic elements just to
demonstrate how they work so now i'm going to add a detail semantic element and inside a details
element you want to add a summary element now the summary if this was a product we might just put
warranty information in here as the summary here i'm going to put something that's more like a
question and it will display how the details and summary work so i'm going to say guess the number
of hours i code per day as our summary now underneath we can put the answer to this question
and now i'm going to put i start at 8 am and i write code for let's say three hours
every morning and we can save that i'll scroll up so we have it up here towards the middle of
our page and now let's scroll up here and let's look at what we have on the page because the rest
of our semantic changes really didn't change the appearance here but this where we added this new
content notice we're not seeing this paragraph at this point we just see guess the number of hours
i code per day but it has this little arrow next to it if we click on this then we see the answer
so that's a nice little addition that this html element adds and again these are all semantic
elements so the aside has some meaning that it's complementary text it's not as important as what's
in the rest of the article the details and the summary work together so this could once again
provide details about a product say warranty information something else the return policy
whatever but you could also use it kind of as a quiz here where you have a question and an answer
let's go ahead and add just a couple of more semantic elements to this one is what we can do
with a highlighter just like you might use a highlighter on a piece of paper there is an
element called mark so i'm going to mark what i want to highlight here in the text and by including
it in the text you know it's an inline element and not a block element so now if i save that
we have highlighted number of hours now inside the answer we're looking at some time here we
have 8am and we also have a duration of three hours we can add some meaning to that in the text
as well and we can provide a time element then we need a date time attribute and for the date time
attribute value i want to put in the actual hours it accepts several values so this would be 0800
on a 24 hour clock and now let's put the closing time element after the 8am here and notice if i
save this right now and show this it does not change what 8am looks like at all but once again
it provides meaning in our html for technologies that are reading it especially those assistive
technologies but it could also provide some meaning for the browser itself now also it says
as i write code for three hours we can provide a time element for the duration too so we have time
once again with the date time attribute and now we'll put in a different value because there is a
value for duration i'm going to put this closing tag at the end of the three hours now let's look
at the value for duration we would put in pt3h and remember there is a link in all of the html
resources that i link to in the description there is a link that shows all of the html elements so
you can look up for example the time element on the mozilla developer network that's the mdn site
and you can look at all the values that could be accepted for the date time attribute okay let's
save this and move down to our vacation area where we also want to add two sections i think
these are clearly defined already where we have subheadings for places i'd like to visit and
really we have a subheading for places i don't want to visit i believe so here let's go ahead
and add a section again lowercase and i'll take that closing section tag highlight it
control x to cut i'll scroll down here and we'll add that before the next subheading so
there we go and save that and of course it reformats again now i'll add a section element
and put the closing after we finish our places i want to avoid section and that would be at the
end of our description list and we can save that now we've got two sections inside of this article
as well and really once again it doesn't change the look but it does change how the browser
interprets and it definitely adds a benefit for assistive technology now before we look at our
document outline with these changes i want to quickly discuss and i'll just do it here by this
comment where it says add more places two different elements that you want to avoid as you're learning
html and then later on you can use them as we possibly get into them with css but there is a
div in an older html code you will see divs everywhere sometimes you still do when those
people that have been using divs are used to still writing them and they just continue
what they've been doing in the past however there is no semantic meaning to a div think of a div
much like a section without the semantic meaning it just stands for divider and really you can
put them anywhere but if you do you really have to do a lot of work to get them to convey meaning
you have to add additional attributes that help assistive technology interpret these elements
because they have no meaning as is they are block elements so a very similar element that is an
inline element if we just wanted to wrap a word or two in a paragraph in an element is span we'll
definitely use some spans as we learn css however once again they have no meaning whatsoever by
themselves they don't change or add any value to your code and we would use them possibly to apply
some css styling to some words that we would highlight around span so we really want to avoid
both of these elements as you learn html really work on using semantic elements and then
when you understand what semantic elements are and how to use them and then occasionally when
just no semantic element is the correct choice that is the time that we actually should use divs
in span so i'm going to delete those for now and save our document and now i'll just scroll our
code up to the very top and i'm going to do the same for our page over here on the right now what
i want to bring your attention to i'm going to maximize the browser and we're going to go to
the chrome web store and look at an extension we can add and that extension is html5 outliner so
search for that you'll find html5 outliner you can click on that and i've got it installed already
so mine says remove from chrome yours would probably say install here and it will look at
our semantic elements and make an outline of our page so let's check that out okay i'm going to
bring our page back down to the size we had it down here to the bottom now once you've got that
extension installed you may have to restart your version of chrome to get it to work but here we
go click on html5 outliner and look we have got an outline of our current page so we've got our
heading hierarchy correct with my goals for the year an untitled nav that's okay we didn't put a
heading in there like i said we could have put an h2 it's just saying we didn't have one but a nav
doesn't require one but remember if you do have more than one nav element per page then you do
need to at least appropriately label that for assistive technology okay now we've got another
section this is our article i'm ready to learn html and that's our h2 heading inside the article
remember we have two sections we have the html5 and my daily schedule and then we have an aside
and this aside was inside the second section it's also untitled which is okay and aside does not
have to have a heading but it just notes that as it's untitled here if you added a heading inside
of the aside say an h4 then it would of course appear there now we've got our other section
this our other article actually this i am also planning a vacation that was an h2 and then these
are h3 headings so you can see how important the headings are the heading hierarchy if you don't
get any other semantics correct in your page that's the one thing to really understand
is the heading hierarchy of a page but all of these other semantic elements definitely help
outline your page and add meaning avoiding these is the biggest mistake you can possibly make as
you are constructing an html page okay now that we've looked at our outline let's once again
validate our page i'll pull this over just so we see a little bit better i'll click file upload
we're at validator.w3.org and i'm going to click choose file i have to make sure i'm in the right
lesson folder i am not so i need to go into html course lesson seven index.html just make sure you
upload the index.html you were working on for this lesson click check and we'll see if we have any
problems if you have a problem it will show here it should tell you what line and what the problem
is but we're good to go document checking completed no errors or warnings to show
let's add a table to our web page tables structure tabular data that is data that's made up of rows
and columns we often see this with schedules statistics in sports and many different types
of data flight schedules for example and what we don't want to use tables for are an entire page
layout back in the 90s and early 2000s it was very common to use a table to structure your entire
html page so you may see some old code that does that but we do not want to do that we want to stick
with semantic html and in the future you'll learn css and we'll design our page layouts with
semantic html and css not tables okay tables do really need a little bit of css to look kind of
accurate however we can start creating a table without css so let's do that now i'm going to
scroll down in our html file and we want to get to this section that says my daily schedule the
subsection and then we describe the daily schedule a little bit and we even have the aside here that
says guess the number of hours i code per day so we want to put some of this in a chart or a table
if we will not really a chart i guess so here we go with a line break and underneath this break
we'll put a table element inside the table element i want to scroll up just a little bit so we can
see this better inside the table element i'm going to type a tr element which stands for table row
and inside the table row we put our data cells and those use td elements which stands for table
data okay the first thing i'm going to do now is start a time element which is going to have a
date time attribute we'll set that equal to 8 am and inside this we'll put 8 am
notice i've pressed alt z already which has my code wrapping down to the next line if it
would extend further so if your code is extending outside of the window here in visual studio code
just press alt z and it will wrap to the next line i'll put a hyphen here and then another time
element with a date time attribute i'm going to set that equal to 11 am and i'll put 11 am here
so now we have 8 am to 11 am in our first data cell and then i'll put the activity in the next
data cell and here we'll put right code now i'm going to highlight this full row and then press
shift alt in the down arrow and it will copy that down so i've created another row quickly so we can
just edit some of the information here so now i'll start at 11 am and then i'll switch the next one
to 12 pm and so there's our one hour for lunch so here we can put eat lunch now let's do this
one more time or i'll highlight the row and then press shift alt in the down arrow and now we'll
have our afternoon time here so this is a 24 hour clock that we need to be aware of as well so we'll
start at 12 pm and now this will be 17 and this would be 5 pm over here so now from 12 pm to 5 pm
we can put in another activity and i'll just say study for other courses and we'll save now let's
scroll down over here in our html and look at the table we have applied no css so we can see the
columns with the times on the left and the activities on the right but it is a little
hard to make out that this is a table so i want to add just a little bit of css to help our page
out i'm going to click on the css file that we've linked to our project scroll down to the bottom
and just paste in just a little bit of css for now this will be available in the files
and once i save that you quickly see how it applies to the table this looks much more like
a table 8 am to 11 am write code and we can see clearly each time block and each activity i'm
going to go back to the html file but i also want to expand the browser to highlight something that
happens here in the code i'm going to right click on the table and click inspect this will open dev
tools and it should be showing the elements now if we highlight the table over here in the elements
tab in dev tools you can see it's highlighted on the page notice all the orange to the right
that is margin that is not table so the table doesn't expand to the width of the page it only
expands based on the content inside the table that is different from some other elements like
the paragraph element notice how it expands for the full width of the page or the ordered list
element that we have here it expands for the full width of the page the same with the aside element
so it's worth noting that the table is different from a lot of other elements that automatically
take up the full width of the page the table element only expands to contain the content
that is within the table okay i'm going to close dev tools resize chrome once again so we can see
our code here on the left and what we aren't missing from a table are headers for our columns
we clearly have a time column and an activity column so let's add that by adding a row at the
top of the table we'll start with the t element again tr element and then inside instead of td
for table data we have th elements for table header so we'll have time and then we'll also have
activity and now if we save that notice that the time and activity are formatted just a little
differently and i did not do anything different for these headings in the css what we have is a
centered heading and it is in bold and that is the default styling that is applied to table
headings now what if we had some data that needed to take up two columns in our table so in other
words one cell would span the width of both columns we can do that so let's add a row at the bottom
and inside the row we'll put one data cell i'm going to put free time inside here for data
but there is an attribute called call span and we can set this equal to two and this will take up
the width of both columns okay now i'm going to remove this call span
and let's put a data cell before free time here and here we'll say inside of this data cell
let's put all other times but for the attribute on this cell let's put a row span which also
exists and we'll have this take up two rows so now let's put another row underneath and in this row
we'll only have one data cell and here we can put sleep now if we save you can see our all other
times is taking up two rows and now we have free time and sleep on the right now our previous
lesson covered html semantics which definitely helps structure a page and tell the browser what
the page is about and it also helps assistive technology like screen readers navigate a page
for those that do not use a mouse for example to navigate the page so let's scroll up and start
adding some semantics to our tables because that is also possible underneath the table the first
element we want to add is a caption so we add the caption and we can say what the table is about
and that would help someone navigating with the screen reader decide if they really want to
navigate the rest of the table or just skip over it and clearly we can also do that visually so
let's just put in my daily schedule like the same title we have for the subsection above in the h3
and as soon as i save that you can see now the caption spans both columns already and is centered
and we didn't have to add a column span for that to happen that automatically happens with the
caption after that we can clearly define sections of a table much like we do sections of a page
so let's start out with the header and this is the t head which stands for table head now i'm
going to go ahead and highlight the closing tag press control x to cut and add it underneath the
end of the row and we can save and here you see the full table head clearly defined it doesn't
change the appearance at all but it adds semantics to our table likewise there is a t body element
for the table body so i'm going to once again highlight the closing tag press control x to cut
scroll all the way down to the end of our table the last row but before the closing tag of the
table and paste the t body tag so now we've got a head and body section for our table
we can also add a t foot section so now inside of the footer i'm going to put another row
and inside the row i'll put a data cell and i'm going to give this a column span equal to two
well i didn't get the data cell started there we go now we go call span equal to two
and inside of here i'm just going to put a statement but you could put something in the
footer that say totals up all of the columns if you had a ledger that was tracking account numbers
or expenses or say you had a sports stats or something like that or anything else that would
need totaled up that would be a good place to put it is inside the footer i'm just going to put a
statement about our schedule i'm going to scroll up before i add the statement but here i'm just
going to put and that's what i do every day comma five days a week period just eat sleep code and
recharge and i'll save and now we can see our footer is spanning both columns and we've clearly
defined the semantics for our table now with a header a body and a footer now another question
you might think of is what if the row needs a header as well it needs some definitions so if
we can have a heading for our column what if we need another kind of official title for each row
as well well we can do that as well so let's scroll up here to the top and in our header
we'll need to put an empty square or an empty cell and we can do that we'll just add another th
and inside of here we need to put ampersand nbsp with a semicolon this is an html entity if you
remember when we covered html entities in a past lesson and that just puts a little small space
inside of the cell now that we've added that we can add headings to each of the other rows
so we'll have a th here for the first row and i'm going to put morning and then in the next row
we'll add another th and i'm going to put break and in the next row th and i'm going to put
afternoon next row th and this is evening and in the final row
well i guess not the final row that would be the footer but this would be the final row
with a row heading and i'm going to put night so if we save this we can really see how our table
has changed but notice we didn't change the call span yet for the footer so we've got an empty
square here as well here's the empty square we defined but we didn't plan on this so we better
change our call span for the footer to three because we now have three columns and if we save
that looks much more like it and you can see when we added the row span and we came down to this
final row and we only added a first and a third column we didn't have to specify that this was
the first and this was the third it automatically knew that because the second column in the row
above is the one that had the row span of two now our page is looking pretty good over here as far
as the table goes but we need to add just a little bit more for semantics and we need to go back and
start at the header to do that so i'll scroll back up and here we are in the t head area of the table
and for each heading that we have on the page each th except this one that has a space in it
we need to provide a scope and that says how it relates to the table so this would be scope equals
to call which stands for column and i'm just going to copy that because we need to add that
to the next one and so time and activity both apply to the columns so as you might guess when
we get down to the next part in the body where we get to the row headings i can paste this in but
i need to change column to row and i'll copy this and we need to apply this to each one of the row
headings so now at break and then we had afternoon evening and finally night and if we save that
once again the semantics don't change the look on the page but we have really helped assistive
technology navigate our table now this is the easier way to do that with scope however that
you may see that accomplished in another way and that is providing an id for each header so if we
had an id and set that equal to time and then we had an id let's say in this row or this row up
here with morning and we set it equal to morning then in the td we would have to give the headers
attribute and specify both so we would say time and morning i find it much easier to just provide
the scope instead of ids and then having to add a headers attribute to each data cell as well
so we'll just leave it at that i'll go ahead and remove these examples that gave the ids
and we'll stick with scope up above here so there we go i just wanted to quickly discuss that that
there is another way to do it now that we've completed adding the semantics to our page
and we're finished with our table let's validate our code i'm going to go to validator.w3.org
i'm going to drag the page over just a little bit click file upload and now when you click
choose file make sure you're grabbing the correct file that you're in the correct folder i'm in the
o8 lesson here it's the folder that i want and i choose the index html and click check and document
checking completed no errors or warnings to show if you have any errors it should show down here
and tell you which line they're on and give you some information about correcting those
so far the html we have created has resulted in one-way communication but in this lesson we're
going to add a form to our html page which will allow users to send information back to us
and that makes our html interactive i've got visual studio code open here on the left with
the starter code for the lesson and on the right we're displaying that starter code in the chrome
browser and i'm using the live server extension to do that live server also immediately updates
the browser with any changes we make in the code adding a form to a web page allows us to gather
information from our users and more specifically it allows our users to send us information if they
choose to this is exemplified throughout the web with contact forms so let's add one to our page
notice i'm near the top of the page around line 13 where the body element starts and if we come
down just a little ways we find our nav element on line 17 now here i'm going to highlight the
last list item in our unordered list that has planning a vacation and i'm going to press shift
alt and the down arrow to just make a copy of that below here i'm going to add another anchor and
remember these are for links within the same page i'm just going to change vacation to contact in
our new link and i'll highlight the planning a vacation and change that to contact me so now we
have made a link that should show up here by our learning html and planning a vacation so i'm going
to press ctrl s to save and there is our new link and now we'll want to scroll in visual studio code
all the way to the bottom and maybe i can just grab the bar here and go a little faster because
after our last article that has the places we do not want to visit on vacation and we can see that
in the browser as well if i scroll that down it may take just a second to get there but here we
are places i want to avoid we want to add our contact form underneath this but above the footer
as well so underneath this last article but before the main element closing tag so i'm on line 170
right now going to add another hr a horizontal rule divider and from there we can start with
our article element i'm going to scroll up just a little to get this closer to the center of the
page or a little higher and then we're going to go ahead and add that id to the article element
and here we'll need this to match what we put in the anchor link above so it needs to say contact
from there let's go ahead and add our header for the heading hierarchy and this should be an h2
as it's a new article area of our page so it matches the other article areas and here i'll
put contact me for the title now let's put a paragraph with a little description underneath
and so in the paragraph i'll just put i'd really like to hear from you there we go and now we have
a title and we have a bit of a description and now we're ready to add our form to the article
so let's start out by typing form and pressing tab notice an action attribute is automatically
added to the form tag and what we want to put here is where we're sending the information
usually this would be to our own server but for this tutorial and just to demonstrate what a form
does we're going to send it to a website that will display the information that we have sent
with the form so let's type https colon slash slash http bin b-i-n dot org and then slash get
now that last part slash get refers to the method we're going to use and that's the next attribute
that we need to add to our form so method equals get likewise method is often post as well there
can be other values and we'll see the difference because we will try both of those out before we're
finished now the contents of forms are mostly labels and inputs and every input should have
a label so let's start with a label element and notice it instantly has a for attribute
that for attribute value should match the id value of the input so here we're going to put first name
because that's what we expect and then for the label this is the part that we'll show on the page
we also want to put first name and then i'll put a colon after that let's go ahead and create an
input and you can also type a colon after the input and type text to get a text input
and then press tab and notice we automatically have the type for the input filled out as text
and now we have a name attribute and an id attribute and these you really want to match
so i'm going to put first name and i forgot to put camel case here for the label but i like
to use that on these so let's go first name and by camel case that means the second word has a
capital so first name with a capital n and then for the name value we'll also put first name that
matches and let's do the same with the id now remember the id is the one that absolutely needs
to match the value of the four in the label this name attribute though is how it is identified
at the server level so when we send this information onto the server the information
that is in this input will be labeled with the value that we put in the name attribute so let's
go ahead and save this much and see what we get on our page we can scroll down and look at our
form it's very basic right now but you can see the title contact me and the paragraph i'd really
like to hear from you and then we have our first name label and our input where the user can type
information in this text input but there are a few more attributes that we can add so let's add
one called a placeholder now this lets us display text but it's not the same as the value which
would actually be what the user enters so this could just be an example i'll type the name jane
and save and now we see jane in the text input but it will not be sent with the form if we click
in that input and then start to type jane disappears and now we have a value an actual
value entered but as soon as i delete the last letter jane will reappear so placeholder is just
exactly that it is holding the place of whatever value will be put in so oftentimes there is
example data in there just to show the user what is expected we can also add another attribute
called autocomplete and autocomplete doesn't expect a yes or no or true or false like others
often do with attributes as far as that goes this is expecting an on or off so we're going
to turn the autocomplete on and that means it will remember other inputs that have been entered into
this field and suggest those so if we were to submit the form and then fill it out again later
it might suggest what we previously put in so that's a preference thing if you want to have
autocomplete on or off then we can put required and this will require this field to have information
from the user before the form can be submitted now notice i said autocomplete didn't use true
or false or yes or no required does but we don't really have to set it equal to
true like this we can just say required because if we put required there it equals true and then
if we don't have required there it's obviously false and the last attribute we'll give this
input is autofocus now only one element in the form or on the page can actually have autofocus
because it can't focus on more than one at once this will put the focus in that input when the
page loads so i'm going to save and then if we reload the page we should see the flashing cursor
here there's focus in there immediately when the page loads so we can start typing instantly when
the page loads in that field now i'm going to leave the autofocus here to have it in the source code
for you for the lesson however with the contact us page being at the bottom of the page it may
not be where you'd really want to have autofocus if you were creating a form okay and that completes
our first label and input combination for our form now i'm going to highlight both of these
and press shift alt and the down arrow so i can copy this down and i'm going to change first name
i'll press control d to highlight every instance of first name which we have three and then arrow
to the front of it and then go three letters in and just switch it to last name so we can change
all of those at once again that's control d and it will let you select more than one at a time for
each time you press control d okay so now we have last name we need to change here that didn't change
this instance of it because we had a space between it so it was not the same as the others and we
don't want to placeholder jane for last name so we'll just put dough and then autocomplete on
i guess we did it for the other one that's okay but remember only one element or one input can
have autofocus on a page so we need to remove that now let's go ahead and save and you can see
our form has both inputs and labels it doesn't look too great though does it they're just all
running along one line and then wrapping to the next when it runs out of room and with that problem
it may be better to wrap our label and input in a block element that creates that line break so
let's use a paragraph that once again better than using a div a paragraph has just a little more
meaning than an empty div although almost the same in this instance and you will see some use
divs here instead of paragraphs so we've got a paragraph there now let's wrap the label and
input for the last name in another paragraph and save and now let's look at our form it has a
little more space here this looks a little bit better than before okay let's keep adding to our
form i'm going to scroll up again we'll get the last name towards the top of the page i'll
highlight the paragraph and everything inside of it and shift alt and the down arrow once again
and now we'll change last name to password so ctrl d to select every instance of last name again
and i'm going to type password so now we've got a four attribute in the label and then the name
and the id our password so let's change our last name here to a password value for label and type
text also needs to be changed to password so this is a different type of input than we used for
first name and last name for placeholder i'm going to put your secret and autocomplete is not
supported on a password input so we can remove that but we do want to go ahead and require a password
so now let's save and we see our new input down here that says password and that's your secret
for a placeholder but now when i start to type into this input notice it has little dots instead of
the text and actually let me see if i can just enlarge this a little bit so we can see these
better there we go so we see little dots here inside of our input and that is what a password
field does so it doesn't let the user see what is being typed in okay let's scroll up again and i
will highlight the last paragraph with the label and input shift alt and the down arrow to copy
and now we're going to change this one to something different let's say this is a phone number so i'll
once again select well i just wanted the three but it's going to change five now because we had
password in there so many times so we can change the label to have a capital p this is not a type
phone though that doesn't exist however type tell does which is short for telephone so we'll leave
the four attribute on the label the name attribute and the id attribute values all to phone all lower
case for placeholder let's give an example here and i'm going to put 555-555-5555
and if we wanted to leave it required we could but we can add another attribute here too
and i'm going to press enter just to come down a line for this it is the pattern attribute now
the pattern attribute supports regular expression patterns and that's almost like learning another
programming language if you're not familiar i'll at least show you this one that will give a pattern
for a phone number like we have shown in the placeholder so we're saying zero to nine so this
must only be numerical digits and then we'll use a curly brace and put the number three so it should
be three numerical digits then we'll put the dash and now i'm going to put the same pattern again
because we had three more and another dash and then finally it's going to be the same pattern
again because we want all numbers and only numbers but this last one should be four and so that is a
regular expression pattern that would match what you see here for the example now why else would
we put the type tell instead of type text or type number well type number has a little different
display and it actually provides arrows that would have you click up and down we don't want that
but type tell also on mobile devices should bring up a numeric keypad on the screen instead of an
alpha numeric essentially with letters it should just bring up what you would say dial for a phone
number and now that i'm thinking about that the hyphen might not be available on that numeric
pad so let's just make it simpler and go with all numbers here and remove those hyphens from
our pattern too so it can still match so let's save this and now i'll go ahead and copy this
down but we'll look at a example of a number input so we can definitely see the difference
right now we see the phone input and it's input type tell and really we don't see anything any
different here besides that because it still allows you to type a hyphen or an underscore
or anything else you want in this input but we're just expecting numbers and it will have to match
this pattern to allow the form to be submitted so the pattern does enforce what should be entered
into that input and now let's go ahead and highlight phone i'll press control d again and
i'm going to change this value to decade and we've changed the for attribute the name attribute and
the id attribute but the label here that we want the user to see is going to be favorite decade
now let's change the input type to number let's go ahead and just remove all of these attributes
placeholder pattern and required and now let's add a minimum so we'll set the min to 1950 this is
where the range will start let's set the max to 2020 and then there is an attribute called step
and that means the interval in between essentially how many years in this case will we be switching
between values and so we'll just move decade by decade which is 10 years and then the starting
value so what we want to display and we'll start with 1980 so let's save this and now we see our
favorite decade input here at the bottom and when i mouse over notice a couple of arrows appear let
me enlarge this one more time oh i enlarged the code instead here we go let's enlarge the page one
more time scroll up and look at this form i'll shrink the code there we go and so when i mouse
over we see 1980 displayed but we get these arrows so we can arrow down to 1970 all the way to 1950
then i can't go any further likewise i can go up to 2020 and can't go any higher so our step
interval is working and our min and max are also working and it's displaying numbers and now we're
going to look at a very different kind of input so i'll just start over and i won't copy everything
down but i will start with a paragraph element again inside the paragraph element we will have
a label and it has a for value i'll put for coffee because we'll ask what the user's favorite coffee
is so we'll say favorite coffee with a colon and now underneath that instead of an input element
we're going to add what is called a select element now notice it still has a name and id so we'll
name or we'll assign the values coffee to both of these as well the id here still needs to match
the four for the label and we'll still have the same name for the input as it's received at the
server as well now notice we do have a closing select element and so with that closing select
element notice that's already different than the input that does not have a closing tag for the
element but inside of select we need to put options so let's give our first option element here
and it has a value and we'll set this to regular coffee but now that's not what the user sees the
user is going to see what we put between the opening option and closing option tags so here
i'm just going to put regular coffee with caps instead of all lowercase and now for the next
option let's put iced coffee and do the same thing as far as what the user sees
there we go i need to scroll up just a little more and let's look at our next option let's
say this is a latte i hope i spelled that right and let's give another option let's call this
cappuccino cappuccino c a p p u c c i n o there we go that's a little one i don't think about
every day whoa i scrolled because i clicked just a little too far to the right sorry about that
scrolling back down to our cappuccino there it is i scrolled way up by mistake get to the end of
that line press enter add one more option here maybe two option let's put a cortado
and what else could we put oh yes what i like to drink which is an americano
so we've got several coffee drinks now in our list and maybe we should put
other others always good there because there could be something we didn't think of so let's
just put an other selection too and save and now if we look at our form over here
we can see the favorite coffee is here with the select menu and we have to click on the arrow
and then all of our options shown we can choose like i would choose americano we could choose
other any one of these options and the top one is what is showing but we could decide to show a
different one if we set it as selected so in the options let's say we want to display latte by
default we would put selected here in the option and if we save now it displays latte by default
so you can choose which one displays instead of just the top one our code's looking a little messy
here as things started to wrap lines so let me just expand visual studio code for a little bit
and you can see how this looks much more organized when the lines are not wrapping now there's
another element we can put in here to help organize our selections so let's do that and
it's called an option group and that is an opt group so once i tab over it gives us the closing
tag too i'm going to highlight and control x to cut and out of the coffees that we're going to have
because this first group will be coffees it's just the first two options so let's close this here
it will reformat as soon as i save but we also need to put a label attribute which is different
than a label element so this label attribute on the option group let's put coffees with a capital
C because you will find out the user will see this value so now let's save this and we're not
going to look back at the web page yet because we need to put another opt group here for the other
coffees so now that we have that i'll select the closing tag and i'm going to put it after americano
other doesn't belong to a group and that's okay too but let's give another label here for this
group and this will be espresso drinks and save now i'll resize visual studio code and we can look
we still have our latte selected as the default choice but now if we expand this you can see
coffees is in bold we can't choose coffees i can't choose espresso drinks but i can choose regular
coffee iced coffee latte cappuccino cortado americano or other but our list is better organized
because we put in those option groups we can make a couple of other changes too so let's go back
and just look at the code again and these other changes are actually attributes that we'll add
back to this parent select element so one is multiple and that means we will be able to select
more than one choice so we could select iced coffee and americanos and then we want to put a size
value and this size says how many from the list will display on the page at once so if we save
that you'll see what i mean by size now notice we have five values automatically displaying on the
page and notice latte is already selected because we told it to select latte but we could also hold
down the control button and click regular coffee and now we have two selected at once and i just
noticed my typo in the label where i only have one e in coffee so i better fix that put the other e in
at the end of the word and save okay i'm going to expand visual studio code once again now this
looks nice on our page and it allows us to select more than one coffee and that's great but i want
to show another input that we could use for this same type of data so right now starting on line
199 i'm going to highlight everything down to 214 now from the edit menu i believe there is yes
toggle a blocked comment and i do this with shift alt and the letter a so i'm going to select all
this once again this paragraph and press shift alt and the letter a and when i do that notice
it comments everything out so i've kept the code if we want to go back to that but this is an html
comment that we have previously gone over in the past lesson and it just comments the code out for
now so i'm going to paste in another way that we could use this same information and present it
to the user so here's the paste and let me go ahead and return there so we have the paragraph
on a separate line but notice we have a label it's for coffee it says favorite coffee now we
don't have a select we have an input type and it's a text type and then it has a list attribute and
it says the list is the coffee dash list then notice we have a data list element and that id
matches the list attribute of the input coffee dash list then i've got some values here that
are much like the values that we saw in our select menu so this is just another example now
let's save this and go back and look at our page and see what we've got it looks like a text input
now when i mouse over notice the arrow and if i click the arrow there's our choices that we're
getting from the data list but what is nice about this if i just click in there they pop up and i
can start typing and then it just narrows it down it filters the list to what i started typing so
that's a different type of input that can handle very similar data presentation so okay what i'm
going to do now is highlight that data list leave it in the code for you but comment it out again
i pressed shift alt and the letter a to do that and i can reverse this comment by doing the same
thing so again line 199 all the way down to 214 shift alt and the letter a and now it is uncommented
and so we've got our original list back with the select and i'll save that and you can see that now
on our page over here on the right okay i'm going to expand visual studio code again and now so far
we have got fairly good semantics for our form because we are applying a label with the proper
for attribute for every type of input that we have and that's good but when a form gets large
sometimes it's good to organize it into different sections sections that say what each part of the
form is about so underneath our form element the opening tag here i'm going to type a new tag
called field set and now i'm going to go ahead and copy that closing tag for the field set
and come all the way down to just above our closing of the form as well because this will
be a section where we've asked about the different information such as the name and your favorite
coffee and so on and now inside of this field set we can specify one more element and this
is called legend it's a lot like a caption and this is just saying what we're requesting in this
section of the form and i'll put personal info here and then we can save now let's go back and
look at our form again and you can see it's surrounded this section of the form because
we're going to add more to it yet so we just sectioned off part of our form essentially
it's got a square around it and personal info the legend is part of that frame of this section of
the form and clearly this does give some more semantic meaning actually conveys meaning in our
structure as we define part of the form and what it's about okay let's continue to add to our form
now because there's some other types of inputs we want to cover so let's scroll all the way down
by our field set and now after the field set we'll put in a break and then we can add a new field
set so inside this field set we can add another legend element and we're going to say what is
your favorite food so this section of the form is all about choosing a favorite food
we'll start with a paragraph inside this paragraph let's have an input before the label this time
and this is going to be type radio radio inputs are a little different but let's give it a name
attribute and this will be for food and now the id attribute is going to be different than the
name this time so we're going to say tacos this is going to actually be more like what the value
of the input is and we'll assign that value attribute and here we'll say tacos as well
so now that we've done that let's go ahead and put the label underneath and there we can have the
four which it should still match the id which is tacos and then what do we want to show in the
label well of course tacos with a capital t okay now that we've done that we've created one radio
button so we need to do a couple more so we have other food choices i know tacos is the proper
choice but we should have a couple of other choices here so i'm going to just do shift alt
in the down arrow twice we've copied those down we're going to leave the name attribute food on
all of these and that's because you should only be able to select one of these so when we select
one the other choice should not be selected and that's what we achieve by giving them all the same
name for the input but as far as tacos for the id and the value we can change that to pizza
and we of course should change pizza here oh and i should have changed the four here to pizza as
well so there should be three now this last one let's go ahead and select all three tacos change
it to other and then here we'll say other as well now i should note that if we had an id of other
we didn't with our option up here that was separate that had just the value of other as
far as the option and the name and the id was coffee so we're good but you don't want to double
up you want to make sure you have individual or unique ids for each input in your form okay now
that we've added our new field set with the choices for our favorite foods let's take a look at that
back on our page so if we scroll up we've got what is your favorite food and since they're all in
paragraphs which are their own block elements they're each on their own line inside of our
field set so we can choose tacos but then because they all have the same name food if i choose
pizza tacos is no longer selected and it's only pizza so you want to make sure out of the radio
buttons they all have the same value for the name attribute okay let's scroll down a little
more and let's add another field set and we'll look at another type of input
inside this field set we'll have a legend as well and here we're going to say do you have pets with
a question mark and now for our inputs they're very similar to radio buttons but not quite the
same so i'll start out with a paragraph input and the type is not text it is check box and then
once again there will be a name and we'll set this equal to pets and the id is going to be equal to
dog and then the value is equal to dog so you can see the pattern is much like when we were adding
radio buttons let me expand visual studio code so this will be a little easier and now we'll go
ahead and add a label after that and the label value will be for dog and what we will display
on the page will be dog as well so very similar i'll highlight this we'll copy this down three
times so now we'll continue to have the value pets for each one of these inputs but the next pet
will switch from dog to cat and we'll put cat here on display as well and then maybe we want a fish
we'll switch this to fish and then finally we could think about doing an other as well but
remember we can't have an id that says other here too we would be doubling up on that so
that could be a problem let's say and select all three and say other pet and from there
we could say other because we just need this to be different the id specifically needs to be
different than any other id on the page or in the form now let's save this and look at the page and
there will be a difference between the radio buttons because when we ask do you have pets
and we have a checkbox maybe we have a dog and a fish and we can select more than one at once
a radio button won't let us do that but a checkbox will so maybe we have a dog and a frog so we
choose other you can select as many of these or as few of these as you want to okay let's expand
visual studio code again and we're down to our last input type so we've covered quite a few today
already let's add one more field set and inside of here another legend as well and let's put
it send me a note so inside of this field set we're only going to have one input but it's
definitely different than the others this one is going to have a label and in the for area
we'll just put message and here we'll put your message and now underneath the label let's go
ahead and add a line break just to give it a little space and then we'll add our input which
is a text area this should have a name and an id and you can also see it's automatically given
columns and rows so for the name value we'll put message likewise that should be the same for the
id since it needs to match our four and for the columns and the rows let's just leave it to the
defaults here that visual studio code gave us it's 30 columns that would be how wide it is and rows
10 rows would be how deep it is so now inside the text area here we could put a value already
this would be the value or where the user would type but i don't really want to do that i want
to leave it blank but we can add some other attributes so for those attributes or attribute
i should say let's add a placeholder and inside of this placeholder we can go ahead and put type
your message here and then we'll just leave this blank but if you were to put it here it would be
like a text input setting the value attribute but you don't really do that for a text area you
would just go ahead and type whatever you wanted to right there and it would be the value in the
text area so let's save this and now let's look back at our form again if we scroll down we can
see an area where we're ready to type a message hey this is my message there we go so that you
commonly see on a contact us form you might have a area for the email for a different message
and so on but this would be where you would typically type a paragraph and i just mentioned
email that is another type of input actually besides text and passwords so you could say it
would be a type email it looks like a text input but it looks for the at symbol to make sure it's
inside of the input as well so i did not cover all inputs today but we covered many of them
and now we have a full form but we're definitely missing something yet we have no way to submit
our form after we fill it out so we need to add submit button or buttons at the end let's start
out with one so after that final field set we'll put in another line break and then let's put in
a button element now a button element should have a type we'll set that equal to submit note you
might also see a form that has a type and here we should put submit there we go so you might see
an input with a type submit and that can also create a button the main difference here is that
it only takes a text value and that's what will show up on the button inside of a button element
you could actually put more things than just a text value inside of the button element so that
that is a big difference i like to use the button elements overall because once again it's a little
more semantic here we're saying it's a button and then we can just set the type to a submit button
so here inside of the button i'm going to type submit and that's what will show up on the button
so let's go ahead and save and now if i scroll down we can see our submit button here that is
ready there's another type of button though too and let's add it to our form and let's go back
and put a type set this equal to reset so if we wanted to reset our form and clear out all of the
values it's fairly handy to have a reset button every time i save it's going back up but there
we go submit and reset and submit when you submit a page it checks the validation immediately so
notice when i clicked that submit button it said i needed to fill this value out because it's
required and we didn't put a value in there so i'll do that again it instantly takes us up here
and says please fill out this field so we've got more than one required let me put dave in the
first name go back and click submit again notice it takes me to last name and says please fill out
this field so it's going to do that for every required field until they're all filled out so
we could put in anything in the password field and i don't think we required anything else let's
take a look though maybe we did nope phone number is required so one two three four five six seven
eight nine and let's leave it at that and it says please match the requested format it knows
we haven't matched yet so i need one more number that should be good now if i submit it's submitted
now let's go ahead and look at this what are we getting from HTTP bin and boy that is bright
but i'm going to make this larger we see it's labeled as args which means arguments what we're
sent with the form we didn't have everything filled out yet but it did send our default value
for coffee and decade as well we didn't have a message but it did at least show that it was an
empty message and it shows what else we filled out including the password notice that doesn't
mean it's encrypted it just didn't show it to us as we entered it so we have to consider that if
we're sending any sensitive information too but overall that is what we got so we could fill out
the rest of the form and see how all that looks let's resize the browser again boy that is bright
when we look at that information but notice when we went back the information is in all of these
other fields but it's not in the password field we would have to re-enter that every time and
that's just part of being with the password field so for favorite coffee let's choose a couple here
i'm biased i want to choose americano because that's my favorite tacos is the correct answer
here do i have pets let's go with dog and other because well i've got two dogs really and then
we've got your message so i'll just put hey this is uh a message there we go let's submit again
it's going to be bright i know but okay nice it fits on here the rest of this down below is
headers and just information about how it was submitted with the browser so that's server
information but this is what we're looking at notice now coffee gave us both values we got the
latte and the americano we got decade first name oh and the server sorted this in order of fields
so food comes after first name before last name there's tacos last name and a message and so on
so we got everything we expected to right there let's add one more button to our form and this
one will allow us to do something that we haven't done before and that is override what we are
setting in the actual original form action and method so this will also be type submit
and you can have more than one submit button perform and now this instead of just having an
action attribute will have a form action attribute and here we can provide a different address
to send the information to when we press this button so i'm going to use a very similar address
it will be to the same website https colon slash slash let's go ahead and expand visual studio
code so we have some more room here there we go http bin dot org slash post so we're going to use
the post method instead of the get method and now for the next attribute instead of just method
method this is form method and we'll set this equal to post and so on the button itself instead of
submit i'm going to put post and we can save and now this will allow us to submit the same information
with a post instead of a submit now notice all the information is cleared out because we
successfully submitted before so i need to enter in at least the required information again
and i believe that was the first four fields
79 put a one there we should be good and now let's go ahead and just press post and see what
we get so we send it post now to the same website and you can see from the form not just
args as they were processing with the git request however this is of course just for
this server it could be processed differently on a different server but we have our labels and we
have the information from the form what's important to note is that it says the origin where it was
sent from and different things here and it says the url at the very bottom where it was sent to
and that is what we specified so now let's look at the same thing if we are to send this information
and i need to put information back inside of the password i guess it didn't clear out because it
was submitted before i incorrectly said that it cleared out because we made a change and saved
the html again so it reloaded here with live server but if we scroll to the bottom now and
just submit and this is remember is a git request not a post request now of course this
htt bin shows this as args up here instead of under the form heading but once again we get all
of our information but what i want to show you is when i scroll to the bottom look at the url
now all of our information is shown inside the url and that's what happens with a git request
so you never want to send sensitive information with a git request because if we looked up here
at this url we would see all of the information inside of it matter of fact i'll expand this it
will be bright again but there is all of our information in the url and that's what happens
when you send a git request okay headed back to our form resize so now you have added a full
contact form to your html page and this is maybe a larger form than you would often add
but overall we've covered quite a few inputs but remember to follow the mdn links in the description
because there are even more inputs that i didn't have time to cover okay we've reached the end and
it's time to validate our page let me expand chrome here and we've got validate by file upload
we're going to choose a file and i'm going to be in my lesson nine and choose the index you
choose the index.html you've been working on and then we'll click check just to see if we have any
errors or if everything validates so we've got document checking completed no errors or warnings
to show that's what we want if you do have errors it will highlight those welcome to your html
project for beginners you'll be using everything you've learned about html5 to build a website for
the little taco shop let's begin the html project let's get started by looking at the little taco
shop website so we've got a basic website here that we created with html it has a nav menu at
the top and an image here in the header and then we've got a description that says about lts which
is an abbreviation for little taco shop and we can see that linked in the nav so instantly we know
that is an anchor link and when we click it it takes us directly to that part of the page
has some information about lts and it even has some emphasis on text here where it says love of
tacos we can see some taco emojis and there is a link in the directions to emojipedia where you can
get emojis and just paste them in with your text emojis do work in html there's a taco trivia
section and you'll have to go back in the lessons and remember how we showed something in the html
and then we're able to click the arrow and it shows more information this is all done with html not css
css very minimal css is applied and available in the style.css file inside the css folder
if we scroll back up we can see there's also a link to our menu and if we click that it takes us
to the part of the page that has the menu and here the menu is a table so you'll have to go
back over your knowledge of html tables and how to create this table once again minimal css
is already available and it will apply to the table as you create it of course there's also
a back to the top link and we've got some copyright information with an html entity for
the copyright sign at the bottom if we click back to the top we're back at the top and we need to
look at the store hours page and once we click that it navigates to another html page so we've
got index.html and now the second page is hours.html it also has a navigation menu at the top as you
can see it's an unordered list and you'll need to remember how to create that and now notice this is
different now we have a link to the home instead of the hours page so it's not just the same
navigation it adapts to what page of course and you'll have to create that for each page we've
got another image and once again the image has a caption and then we've got the hours this looks
like a list but you'll need to remember what type of list creates a list that looks like this
where it says we're open seven days a week which is a description such as a paragraph but then
this part starting with sunday and going through the hours is all a list we've got back to the top
again and we've got the same information in the footer so let's click back to the top and we
have our menu now let's go to the contact us page and on the contact us page you can see there's a
link now back to the store hours and also links to home and the different parts of the home page
now that's something to consider too that we're not just linking to another page but we're linking
to a section of that home page then there is the image little taco shop tacos for the caption
and we've got the contact form and you can go back over the forms tutorial to learn how to
create this form and you can submit this form just like we did in the forms tutorial we aren't
creating the back end that will process the form but you can set it up to submit to the site we
used in the forms tutorial that will just show the information submitted and then there is an
our location section and if you remember the html element to use for an address this is what you
want to put inside of that and look the link to the phone number and if you're on a mobile device
this of course is a false or fake number but this should actually work as a phone number if you
create the correct link and we've got back to the top again and that pretty much covers the site
but just to reference let's go ahead and click the about lts which will not only take us to the home
page but to the specific part of the page so you also want to be able to link to that specific
part from another page not just on the page itself such as when we clicked about when we
were on the home page and it took us directly there so you can also do that from other pages
now as we look at the starter files for this project not only is there a readme.md file that
has the directions and these directions are in a markdown file that's what.md is and this is
making it very easy to read on github where you look at the resources and so you can also just
read them in here like this but the other beginner files are already here so you've already got a
fav icon that you would link to in the head of each page you've already got some css inside of
the css folder and you can link to this style.css in the head of every page as well you've got all
three images one for each page here and you've got some examples and these examples are important
because you'll want to go back and reference that you don't necessarily have to always go
back and pause the video you can just click on the image and i have made full screen captures
of the entire page so you don't have to scroll you could zoom in a little if you want to
but you have these to reference so here's the contact page when it shows up there we go
and there's an hours capture as well so you've got one for home one for hours and one for contact
and you can reference these visually to help you create these pages it looks like it just takes a
little bit to show up inside of visual studio code of course you could open these image files
with some other software if you want to as well or directly in the browser and just keep different
tabs open to view each image file if you want to that would also work so there you go you've got to
create three html pages here in the root of your tutorial folder and then reference these other
files and you've got the examples to look at and you've got the favicon file already as well
so if we go back to the directions let me see if i left anything out you've got your files all
named index hours and contact we talked about that minimal css available inside of the styles
file styles.css all images are provided and if you need taco emojis here's a link to that as well
and the favicon is included so that's everything good luck with the challenge and then of course
after this you want to pause the video and complete it to the best of your ability and then all walk
through and create these pages with you for the solution afterwards so don't do that now pause the
video and actually attempt it on your own that's the best way to get better at something try this
out for yourself before you allow me to walk you through it okay let's get started building our
project i'll close this readme.md and i'll close any image file that we had open before matter of
fact i'll collapse the examples and we're just going to create the three html files that we
need first we need index.html and then we also need contact.html and if i remember right we need
hours.html okay with our three empty files created let's go ahead and start on the first one which
is index.html we know every document starts with doc type and if i press tab it adds the html from
there we know we need the html i need lowercase or i prefer lowercase and then we need the attribute
lang and that equals english is what i'll put of course you could put something different there
if you want to we instantly get the closing html tag if you don't of course add that as well from
there let's create the head section so here's the head element i've got the closing head element
and this will contain several meta elements the first one has the character set attribute and we
specify utf dash eight after that i have another meta and this is going to be name equals author
and of course this should be your name i'll put my name here so dave gray after that meta name
equals description and this is where we describe the page so once again we have a content attribute
and i'm going to put the official website for the and i need to press alt z to wrap the code here
little oops i didn't get a space little taco shop and i should really put a capital t there as well
because it's the official name okay so we've got the little taco shop and of course that's
what our title will be for the page as well so we want the little need to spell this correctly the
little taco shop in the title as well after the title let's add a link and here we're going to say
rel which is related it's an icon and the href and now let's put in that fav icon that we have
and after that we'll say this is type equals image slash x dash icon and now let's add one more link
tag and how it's related to the page is it's a style sheet and now the href will point to that
css style sheet so we need there it is css and then we want style dot css and after that we can
close our link tag and we're finished with the head so i'm going to press control s to save
now i could copy this much and paste it into the other two pages and just make a few changes
but i'm going to do just a few more things before i do that so just underneath the head we'll start
our body element and then in the body element we'll start with a header element inside the
header element we're going to have an h1 and we'll say welcome to the little still not typing that
right there we go the little taco shop and that is our h1 heading for the page remember every page
should only have one h1 header i'll scroll up now for some more room and now we'll start our nav
element this is where our navigation menu will be we get that closing element inside the nav
element we're going to have an unordered list and then each list item will have a different link
so here we'll start out with well let me put a line in between there we go let's start out with
our anchor tag and the href is going to equal hashtag about so this is going to link to an
about section on this page so i'll say about right there and then after that let's go ahead and put
an abbreviation element inside of our link and here we can give a title to this abbreviation
and this will be the little i spelled it right that time taco shop and then we'll close that out
and since we're abbreviating we'll put lts so our link says about lts and now we can just copy this
link item down so highlight the full li and then i press control alt and the down arrow it should
be the same for you on windows it may be a little different on a mac or linux now the next link is
much easier here so we'll just say about and it's hashtag menu i want all lowercase again
so no abbreviation for the menu so it's just about menu or i'll put our menu i think that's
what's actually on the page and then from there we can copy this down once again a little easier
for the next link and let's copy it one more time there we go three hour menus let's change
this second menu that's the hashtag menu to our hours.html so we're linking directly to another
page now and then we can put store hours and then for this last one we'll remove the hashtag menu
and we'll put our contact.html and then we'll put contact us here instead of our menu
now i'm going to scroll just a little bit more and while we're still in the header
out of the nav but in the header i'm going to add a figure and then inside this figure
we'll add our image so here's our image element and we'll give it a source equal to and then we
want to specify our image folder and then let's pick our tacos and drink image and once we have
that image we can add some alt text for that that actually says what it is so we'll put tacos and a
drink remember alt text makes our images more accessible and then we have a title and we'll say
we love tacos the title does not have to be the same as the alt text and then let's provide the
width and i notice i saved the width and the height in the image name so the width is 400
and then the height equals 267 and we can close out our image tag but we're not quite finished
with our figure yet let's go ahead and add a fig caption element and inside this we'll give a
description once again tacos and a drink as our caption for the image okay now we've completed
the header so let's once again scroll up for some more room and then in between the header
and the main element let's put a horizontal rule and after that let's put a main element where
the body of our page will be and right now let's leave a comment saying our content will go here
and then after that we'll have another hr and then we'll have a footer element and now we need
to put something in the footer as well if you remember from the example each footer had a
paragraph that said copyright and now we need to use an html entity for the copyright symbol and
that is ampersand copy with a semicolon and then we'll just say the little taco shop and now we
can save this and now we're really ready to copy all of this code and put it into the other pages
as well and we'll just need to make a few changes and then when we add actual content to each of
the pages that's where it will really differ so i'm going to press ctrl a to highlight everything
and then ctrl c to copy everything go to the contact page and press ctrl v to paste that in
ctrl s to save go to the hours page and do the same ctrl v to paste it all in and ctrl s to save
okay while we're on the hours page let's make the changes here first i need to press alt z again in
each one of these files to get the code to wrap in each one so now we can make our changes everything
is the same as far as the author and the content but when we get to description we'll have a
different description this will be store hours for the little taco shop and now that we've changed
our description we can also change our title instead of the little taco shop here let's put
lts hours since it's not the home page we'll just go ahead and abbreviate as we can assume the owner
employees and even the townspeople in the little town for the little taco shop refer to the little
taco shop as lts now let's scroll down into the body where we have our header and a little bit
needs to change here too so it's not welcome to the little taco shop here we'll put the little
taco shop and then hours after that and now our nav is going to change somewhat too so it's not
just a link to about lts we need to go to another page and if you remember we can just go to the
slash to go to the home page so here we need slash about to go to the about section of the
little taco shop on the home page so we'll do the same for the menu and now where we have hours we
can just eliminate this because we're going to put in a home link instead so i'm going to press
ctrl x to cut it out then just backspace out that extra line here scroll to the very top
and paste in the one that i just cut out and now we're going to link to just that slash that i was
talking about and that will link to the home page so let's change the store hours to home
and i'll save that much now let's scroll down a little bit further and we need to change out
our image as well so now we're not going to use the tacos and a drink image we wouldn't want that
on more than one page so now i want image slash and we'll choose tacos tray now notice it's also
400 by 267 so we don't need to change that but let's change what it says here for the alt text
and we'll say a tray of tasty tacos and then we can add a tray of tasty tacos for the fig
caption as well i should have just highlighted that copy and paste again control c over the fig
caption and control v and we could leave we love tacos for the title here as well but let's put
we love trays of tacos that's some nice title text as well and remember the title shows when
you put your mouse over the image and if we scroll down we don't really need to change anything
because the footer stays the same between all the pages so we're finished with the immediate
changes to the hours html now let's go make those same types of changes to the contact dot html i
need to scroll back up to the top first and press alt z to get the code to wrap now we need to change
the description again so let's change this to contact information for the little taco shop
and let's change the title for the page as well and here we'll put contact us
and then let's put a dash and put lts just because we want the lts in the title for everything that's
not the home page and we leave everything else the same so now we can scroll up and this is the
contact us page so let's highlight this h1 change this part to contact us and now for the about
once again we could actually go over to the hours and now let's copy this nav and we'll just have
to change a little bit less that way so copy the nav and now we'll highlight the nav that we have
in here and paste in the new one from the hours page so now we have the same home link we have
the same about link we have the same menu link and we only need to change contact to hours so
this will link to hours and then we just change this contact us to store hours and let's save
that much okay scrolling down to the figure we need to change out our image again this one's
just a little different so now we've already had tacos and a drink and the tacos tray this is
tacos close up and notice the size is a little different 400 by 260 so we've got 400 here we
need to change this to 260 instead of 267 okay now our alt of course will be a little different
as well this will be little taco shop tacos and now for the title let's put tacos ready to eat
and then we can put little taco shop tacos here too so i'll once again highlight that alt text
and put the same text in here for the caption that we're showing on the page and if we scroll
down we can see our footer remains the same here too so let's save the page and we're ready to
begin working on content for each of the pages okay i'm going back to the index html and i'm
going to click go live or i could right click and choose open with live server because we're using
the live server extension to view our web page and we can go ahead and start looking at our page
it doesn't have a lot on it but it has enough to get started here we've got our header section
and we've got the menu with the different links so i'm going back to the code i'm going to resize
visual studio code and press ctrl b to hide the file tree so i have more room to see the code
and we're ready to add content to the page inside of the main element i'll delete that and we'll
start with an article element i'm going to give this an id equal to about so our about anchor tag
works our link works now i'll put an h2 and inside the h2 i'm going to put about and then
we need that abbreviation with the title value again of the little taco shop
and now we'll put lts there we go and that completes the header so now let's put some content
we'll have a paragraph here and i'm going to take that same abbreviation and start the
paragraph with that so lts was founded in and now remember we can use a time element to give
some meaning to the dates and times we put on our page so i'm going to put a time element here
with a date time equal to 2022 so the little taco shop is a fairly new location
get a period at the end of that sentence and we can put our shop was built on or it was built
from there we go a love of tacos and then we'll put a period there we'll say we hope
our shop adds a unique and interesting place to our little town now let's add just a little more
flavor to this paragraph so we can put a strong element and then we'll put love of tacos inside
that so it has some emphasis and now we also want to add some taco emojis right after that so
let's go to a new window and i'm going to type in emoji pedia.org and there you can search for
emojis i'm searching for taco and once i find taco i'm going to click that and it allows me to
copy that emoji so after i say a love of tacos i'll put a space in control v control v control v
just paste it in three tacos so i'm going to close out emoji pedia we no longer need that
but let's save this and see what we get on our page so now if we look at this we've got about
lts and there's the abbreviation and when we mouse over we get little taco shop
and now we've got our paragraph for the about information now i'm going to scroll up just a
little more but right after the paragraph i'm going to use another semantic element called
aside if you remember that one and for the aside i'm going to put an h3 header so we're following
that header hierarchy put taco trivia so for taco trivia we're going to have a question that only
shows the answer when you click on it and for that we need to start out with a details element
and then inside the details element we're going to use a summary element so inside the
summary is where we ask the question and we can say when did tacos first appear in the united
states and now the nice thing is this question will show but you'll have to click an arrow
to see the answer that is contained within and that's within just the rest of the details here
and it's a paragraph now i'm going to copy and paste this paragraph in and put it right here
and notice i added another time element here with 1905 and we can save that much and we can see our
taco trivia down here at the bottom and when we click we see the rest of this but there's just a
little more i would like to add and it actually has one element in there that was not covered in
prior lessons but remember there is a wealth of information and many different elements that still
remain uncovered i guess they're not used as often but you can look them up on the
mozilla developer network so i'm going to put in a citation and there is an element in there called
site so right after this i'll paste in the citation and here you can see i put the source
let me expand visual studio code that's getting a little cramped you can see i put the source
and then i put a site element c i t e and inside that site element i put the link to the source
so that is right there and that's smithsonian magazine so now if i save i'll resize once again
to come back and look at our taco trivia and when i show the information you can see the citation
is put in italics by default with that site element okay let's resize visual studio code
again to get a little more room and scroll up as well after that aside we have really completed
our first article so let's put a horizontal rule in here which also indicates a topic change at
least somewhat in the main area and put another article now this article i didn't add the id but
it needs the id because the id equals menu and this is where we will put the little taco shop
menu we'll start with an h2 again to follow the header hierarchy for our page and we'll put
our menu for that and then we'll start our table element inside the table element the first thing
we're going to add just immediately if i could start is a caption there we go and we'll just
put our tacos for the caption after that we need a t head inside the t head will be a table row
and the table row is going to have our columns and these are our heading columns so the first one
so the first one is tacos after tacos we're going to have a second th and this th is going to have
well let me go ahead and type th again there we go this th is going to have a scope and let's set
this scope equal to column because it's for the column and then we need our abbreviation element
once again so let's type abbr and then we'll put the title equal to quantity and now we can put
in the abbreviation for quantity that we want to use which is commonly qty and then we'll add
another th and it will also have a scope let's set this equal to column as well and this will be
the price column okay going to scroll up as you might have realized when we learned about tables
tables take up a lot more space as you create them in your code so we've completed the head and we
need more room for the body of the table let's add a new row and inside this row we're going to add
another heading but this will have a different scope so now that we're back there we'll go scope
equals row and now that we're ready to put in the value let's call this crunchy but i did forget an
attribute this also needs a row span so this will have a row span equal to three okay after we've
created the scope and the row span with crunchy we can't forget the values of the other columns
so now we need one for the quantity and for the next one which was price we need a dollar 50 so
there's our first row and now we can create more rows but what i really want to do is just take
these last three and you shift alt in the down arrow and then add an opening tr here i wanted
to add a closing tr as well but we don't need that because this crunchy is taking up three rows
so we don't want to add that row down here we just need the other two rows so let's turn this one
into two dollar or two quantity of two and two dollars and fifty cents now i'll just highlight
this row and take it down one more time and we'll have a quantity of three and we'll put three
dollars and twenty five cents so now we've got the feel of this where we've got the first one
with the title and it's taking up three rows and then we've got the quantity and the price
so what i want to do for the next one is to just highlight all of these and press shift alt in the
down arrow and once again just make changes so this is going to be soft instead of crunchy
and now we've still got a quantity of one but is the price the same and no it's not soft tacos are
a little more expensive so two dollars and then for two soft tacos it's 350 and for three soft
tacos it is 450 now let's scroll up some more we've finished with the body but we need to add
the footer to the table and that's the t foot element and now inside the t foot we're going
to have a table row and then we'll have a data cell table data and it's going to have a call span
attribute so it's going to span all of the columns so that's three and then inside of the table data
we'll put chips and then and amp is for the ampersand that is another html entity and then
we put salsa two dollars and now we've completed our table but underneath the table in this last
article let's go ahead and put a line break and after the break let's put a paragraph and let's
go ahead and add our back to top link so now we'll have an a with an href we'll set this equal to the
hashtag which should just reload the page take us back to the top and we can save so now let's
resize visual studio code and see if we have all of our content yes we've got the crunchy that took
three rows and the soft that took three rows there's the table footer everything looks like
we planned it and our back to top link is here it takes us back to the top as well our taco trivia
everything is good about the home page so now let's work on the store hours page it is a fairly
short page and there you can see it displayed to the right and we'll pull up the code here on the
left okay let's scroll down and we've just got a little bit of content to add in the main area
here of the body inside the main element so we'll start out with a paragraph and inside this
paragraph we'll just say we are open seven days a week with an exclamation mark after that we need
to add a data list so it starts out with a dl element inside the dl element we'll have a dt
and this is where we'll put our sunday dash thursday so sunday through thursday and then
underneath that we'll have a dd element and that's where we'll put our 11 am dash 9 pm
so now we can just copy this down because there's only one more those like it and we can just
change the days out so now this will be friday saturday and then the hours are different as well
it's 11 am to 11 pm and we can save that now we also need to add a back to the top link as well
so here's our paragraph and then we can say a with href once again equal to the hashtag
and back to top and save once again and now we can see all of this here on the right
our back to top really isn't needed because it's so short but we're just consistent between each
page and that's fine so now let's go over to the menu page or not the menu i'm sorry we want to go
to the contact us page that's where we are the menu is on the home page i don't know about you
but i'm starting to get hungry when i look at those so let's finish up this project so we can
go get some tacos i'm going to scroll up and once again we're going to change out the comment inside
of the main element and put in our content we'll start with an h2 following the header hierarchy
remember we already have contact us up here in the header i believe if we scroll up there there's
the h1 so we want an h2 here and this h2 is going to say our contact form okay now we need to go
ahead and create this form so we'll start with the form element and let's go ahead and give it
an action oh there we go form tab over and it gives us the action there we go and we'll send
this to that same website we used in the forms tutorial that's http bin.org slash get so we're
going to use a get method when we submit it and we'll at least be able to see the information
on that website so as i said we use the get method so let's go ahead and apply that attribute
as well method equals get after that i'm going to put some space here in the form and we need a
field set element now we can put our form inside the field set element and then we'll have a legend
element and here we'll say send us a message and then we can start in with the description of our
form so we have a paragraph and then we have a label and then it has a four and this will be name
and so then we need to put name inside the label as we label the input and now we need that input
so here's the input let's give it a type there we go text there it is text now we put in the name
which is name and the id which is going to be name as well and now i want a placeholder element here
also and this placeholder is going to say your name giving the user a clue as to what to put in
and let's put in required as we want the username to be required before they can submit the form
scroll just a little more for some more room i'm going to highlight this paragraph now and once
again shift alt in the down arrow and now i've already got my label and input and i just need
to change some of these things so this will be email and we'll change name here to email as well
and now this will be an email input and then for the name and id i'm going to press control d
for each of those remaining name words and then i can change them all at once to email okay i'm
going to save this much and we see the beginning of our form over here but we still need the area
to put in the message so i think i want to scroll some more for that and then return once again
one more paragraph inside this paragraph let's have a label and now the four here is going to be
message and now inside the label we'll also put well we'll put your message here that's fine
and then we need a text area which is a little bit different than a text input this is going
to have the name of message and it should have the id of message as well columns 30 and rows 10
that's fine that is the default and then placeholder also so let's put a placeholder let's set that
equal to type your message here and then the actual message of course goes inside the text
area so we'll save that and now we should see a place they can put their message oh but we can
see it looks a little different this doesn't look quite right let's put a break after that label
and then it should put the label up on top of that message box now let's scroll a little bit
more and after the field set but important enough before the form has ended we need to put a button
and then inside of this button let's give it an attribute which is type equals submit and then
let's go ahead and put send for the button text i'm going to copy this down control alt in the down
arrow and now this type will be reset so we have a second button and we can put reset here as well
so now let's save and we should see our buttons that will send or reset the form and as i look
at everything i've noticed something we put our form inside the main element but i wanted to wrap
that inside of a semantic tag as well not just the main element but i wanted to put it inside
of a section element so let's go ahead and put a section element there and we will copy that
or cut that actually with control x and scroll all the way down to where the form ends and put
the closing section there now let's save that it doesn't make the page look any different
but it holds up the html semantics better and the main reason we need it is because the form is not
the only content of the page so we have another section here and this section has an h2 of its own
and here we can put our location which goes nicely with a contact us page as well so now
we've got the h2 there and we need an address element because now we can put our location
inside of this address element so it's 555 taco temptation lane and then it's at sweet t
line break and then kansas city
missouri and then 555 55 dash 55 55 completely fictitious zip code after that we'll put in a
line break and another line break and then let's put in a phone number which is also fictitious
but we want an actual link that will work to make your phone or whatever mobile device dial
the phone number and we can do that with the tell abbreviation and then we need a plus and then 555
555 55 55 there we go and then we can put the link so it's 555 dash 555 dash 555
and now we've completed the address section so if we save that and scroll up a little bit
there is the location information and with that i believe we have completed our website in the
three pages so i hope this tutorial has helped and more than that i hope you were able to complete
much of it on your own before watching the tutorial let's expand chrome and look at our
overall site so if we go to the home page here it is here's everything we added here's the back to
the top link that works too we can go to the menu that's great we should be able to go to the about
lts yep that works good too mouse over an image and we get our title text all of that's as expected
store hours everything looks like it should here as well and then the contact us page
everything's looking good here let's go ahead and try the contact us information so then we say
dave at dave dot dave whatever and then dave in the message that's fine send and yes it goes to
the http binn dot org and we see the information from the form and that's a great site to test out
forms on so everything is looking as it should i'm ready to go get some tacos congratulations
on completing your html project